mic check mic check mic check again here
we are guys here we are
seven thousand
109.
and you need 7 500.
to get into
Grand Master
which
I don't know if you can make it any
higher than that being a free-to-play
player I'll be honest with you guys we
have been strictly free to play so far
so this is what we're aiming for guys
this is the goal for today right here
right now
and if you guys have watched us play
this you know it's it's very
for me at least it's been very streaky
I'll go on a streak where I'm just
winning five games here three games
there six games here five games here two
games three games
and then you'll have games where days
where you just lose five in a row win
one lose three in a row win one
we can't have one of those days
we cannot have one of those days
so
when was it it was on Tuesday
I I played so much guys I played so much
so
the ranking right now I'm at 7109 and I
think what is it to get into so Platinum
is 5400 if you reach 5400 then you're in
Diamond so you guys I went up
the day that we were streaming we were
very very close to 6300 then as the
stream went on we kind of we started off
well and then we started doing bad and
then I think we ended up around 6100.
okay
that was the last stream then I played
on Tuesday night
deep into the night into the wee hours
of the morning
and we dropped all the way
down
almost to the Rock Bottom almost to the
Rock Bottom I think we were around 5500
or so
and so what what happened was I kept
running into guys that were just way
higher spell book level than me not
necessarily players that
are whales that it's been a lot of money
on the game
but just just players that had leveled
up more than me so I was like I can't
I I can't keep beating my head against
the wall like this so yesterday
or was it the day before
no I think it was yesterday uh swamp
witch and pharaoh
we joined up went through
the forest
on a higher level than any of us were
and we managed to complete it
I got my first legendary Echo
and look who it was
look who it was baby
the Bellatrix Echo legendary Echo the
cards weren't great on it
but I went ahead and fully upgraded it
and they ended up being pretty darn good
bomb box
oh boy bomb box with the plus one that's
great Cassandra with the plus two we've
been using her and then we also have the
pixie so three of the cards here ideally
you'd like a lot more but my first
legendary what can you say three of
those cards are getting boosted in my
deck right now so you get the bomb box
plus one Cassandra plus two and then the
Pixies plus one huge huge help we also
landed another legendary thunderstorm
card allowing us to upgrade that so
we've been making a lot of upgrades and
we have our Spellbook level up to 38
which honestly a lot of the people that
I've been running into in Diamond are
higher than this so I mean this is this
is an uphill battle
so I'm setting your expectations if we
go in and we start just getting our
wands handed to us
then we might have to back off
we might have to back off all right so
let's see who else do we have joining us
here in the chat
I'm doing well Alicia thanks for asking
hope you're doing well also guys by the
way if uh if you know Dylan from the
chat from the streams from the Discord
Dylan is an awesome awesome Community
member has been a mod I think he's my
longest mod I think Dylan was like one
of the first mods
uh he's he's going to become a father
today
gonna become a father and you know for
anyone who's had a baby you know that
process can be very nerve-wracking
there's a lot of you know emotions are
running High
as expected so I'm sure Dylan could use
any prayers Good Vibes that you can send
his way
um and who knows he might he might stop
in and give us some news I haven't heard
from him uh he he left a message to us
this morning
saying that today was the day
but oh wait hold on did he did he tweet
something
oh no no no he has been tweeting but I
haven't seen a tweet of like uh it's
happening yet
but it's it's happening it's happening
today
we just uh we don't have a baby yet so
Dylan if you see this later I know he
watches a lot on replay Squad we're with
you man we're so excited for you can't
wait can't wait to hear more and Nico
ladies and gentlemen
so good to see Nico Back In The Stream
guys Nico has been working like crazy
lately hasn't had a lot of time to pop
into the streams
but it's good to see the real life Chief
warlock here we also had uh fellow
moderators Tim and elwin in the chat as
well I saw Jenna there in the beginning
calibri welcome how's it going then we
had dark Hussein then we had Osman
Paula always good to see Paula here
Juan Martinez how's it going greetings
from Mexico dude I ran into a lot of
players from Mexico playing this game
a lot of players
you're on Silver Alicia just don't have
the energy
this game has like tapped into my
competitive spirit
which you guys a lot of the guys that
have been watching since
you know kind of the Hogwarts Legacy
days
you don't know how competitive I can get
you don't know
but like Nico who's been around since
the Smash Bros days
he knows how competitive I can get and I
I don't know man like this I've never
been great at like those twitch first
person shooters I've always wanted to be
good but I've never really been good
but whatever it is about this game man
I'm I'm decent at it and it's just like
obviously it's set in a world that I
love struck a chord with me and so I'm
just having a blast you're a wizard
Harry
you're a wizard Anna you can never make
the streams
oh no well you're here right now you'll
have to leave soon
that's when we have the vods but I know
Anna likes to be here live so she can
communicate with all the all the
audience all the fun scada or scatha
welcome in good to see you here and then
Roxy says Pew welcome how's it going
who was that with the uh was that a sub
or was that a member I think that was a
channel member from fairy fairy thank
you so much appreciate it welcome in
let's see if our alerts are actually
working today they're working on screen
for you guys
okay let me do no not reload overlays
that's not what we want to do
that is not what we want to do
oh wait was Dylan here did Dylan pop in
and say hello
Merlin says be sure to kablaminite the
like button helps others find the
channel
hacks off my Death Eaters who may be
watching oh man
oh man we're about to you about to see
some Death Eaters
y'all about to see some Death Eaters you
know me I'm I first play through
Hogwarts Legacy I'm a good wizard
but let me tell you about Bellatrix dude
she's really powerful in this game I'm
embracing the dark side in Magic awaken
embracing the dark side yeah Roxy that's
what we've been using is uh is
BlueStacks it's been working pretty well
for us we are also BlueStacks affiliate
it's a free program if you guys want to
try to play Magic waking on PC until the
official PC Clan is out in your area
which it will be coming at some point
everywhere uh there's a link in the
video description you guys can check
that out it would help the channel I
would much appreciate it
Elisa or Alisa welcome good to see you
here
oh dude
Cowboy dueling tips video launcher from
Silver to platinum let's go that's
awesome calibrate glad to hear that they
helped
so I'll I'll show you guys here what
what we've been uh changing
Darren Jesper with the two dollar Super
Chat Darren thank you so much dude good
luck you got this
I hope so man I hope so so I also I the
other day I don't know why I didn't
think about you guys there are potions
in the game that you can use to help
with this
the draft of peace there's a large one
that will protect you from losing points
or having your tear lowered if you lose
your next three duels
effect lasts for 30 minutes
and then there's also a smaller one
which works for
like your next duel I have two little
ones and one big one left actually you
know what
let's see if we can Brew any
can we can Brew we can Brew uh two
smalls
let's go ahead and do that
so yesterday when I when I went on my
big streak
this was actually kind of crazy it did
not start off that way I hopped on and
you know just just like fresh going in
I'm like I don't want to lose any points
so I used one of the big ones I used the
big one right here and guess what I lost
three in a row
I lost three in a row and if I hadn't
used that I would have definitely tapped
out and said okay we're done for the day
but because I had that I was like okay
let's just try again and then
that's when we went on our streak man
that's when we went on this huge streak
to get to 7 100.
but yeah I'm glad you guys have been
enjoying the tips and Darren thank you
once again for the Super Chat there it
is Roxy there's how close we are
71.09 and we need to get to 7 500 this
has been solely as a free to play player
we have the same amount of points what
no way
you're gonna be honest you thought it
was a Hogwarts Legacy stream
oh man I mean we've got plenty of
Hogwarts Legacy streams and content on
the channel but not a lot of new things
going on with Hogwarts Legacy right now
so been playing uh Harry Potter magic
awaken which has been a really fun game
Tim you've lost a week's worth of
progress due to a dead router got a new
one coming from Amazon any day now oh my
goodness dude
yeah I probably wouldn't want to play
this game on like a wireless connection
either I could see it really running up
your your bill
I could see that
how do I get the legendary Echo so I got
the legendary Echo from the forest
haunted hollow levels
eight
I think it's a level eight
not the solo one because I'm not high
enough to do that yet and actually it
didn't even say I was high enough to do
the haunted hollow level 8 but
I teamed up with two other players from
our from our Discord shout out to swamp
witch and Vero who helped me out and we
were all three like under level though
and we we were able to do it is the boss
that we had was the spider boss with all
the poison around
and so we just ran it took us two tries
the first try we died but then the
second try we said let's all three run
Hagrid Echoes and antipody and opal eyes
which the max that you can have at one
time is four
I didn't know that but you can only have
four at a time so we were running four
antipodian opal eyes all running Hagrid
and because they're flying you know
they're not they don't have to deal with
the poison so they were flying we were
throwing swelling Solutions down and
they just it was just like I don't know
dude it's like that scene out of Game of
Thrones you know when
drogon just comes in and just starts
like
burning everything
the good time the good time not spoiler
alert if you haven't seen yeah the good
time when drogen comes in in the battle
but uh but yeah we had we had all those
dragons going and then I just happened
to get lucky just happened to get lucky
and get Bellatrix who is the X the echo
that I've been using in all of my
all of my uh attempts here
uh yeah it's right in the description
Osman if you um actually it's in the
description how to uh download the
program that runs it but it also there
might be some uh instructions you need
to walk through so if you go and look
back through my previous videos on the
channel there's one called how to play
on PC
and there's a lot of territories where
the official PC client is available
so I'm in the US though and it is not
unlocked yet for our region so hopefully
it will be sometime soon but right now
I'm using a blue the emulator called
BlueStacks
so yeah that's how you do it Metatron
how's it going welcome all right so I
think how I want to start it off let me
make sure we got everything ready to go
yeah this this is the load up Loadout
we've been running I I'm just gonna go
ahead and drink one of the
I'm gonna drink one of the little ones
so the draft of peace right here to
start so that means even if I lose this
match right here we will not drop
now even if we win though
this is kind of like the you know it's a
pretty powerful potion so there's got to
be some downside to it even if we win
this gets used
so even if I win that gets used up it's
not like I'm going to have it for the
next match
how do you team up to do haunted hollow
you've only seen the option to
um oh with in-game Paula do you have we
added each have you added me as a friend
Paula here you need to add me I don't
think I've uh I've seen you on my list
it's retro with all caps like this it is
case sensitive so just r-e-t-r-o
but um yeah so whenever you go to add
add a like a companion you should be
able to see your friends in there as
well
and then you can like go and look at
different tabs so you could do your
social club you could do friends you
could do there's there's a couple of
other ones in there
and actually I didn't know this if you
guys run haunted hollow
has a solo
the enemies actually don't have as much
health
yeah I didn't know that
all right man deep breath deep breath
sip of the Coke Zero here
and we're gonna lock it in
we're gonna lock it in
draft of Peace enabled so no no pressure
on the first run here
no pressure no pressure
so we need to calculate
I'm at seven okay so wait let's see 7
500.
oh my gosh
of course we get rank I'll rank one I've
played this person before
what did it say Dominican Republic
Dominica rain oh my gosh rank one
all right well
I think I've beaten them once but they
usually beat me we play you start to see
a lot of the same names once you get to
this level
start to see a lot of the same names
okay guys here we go
not the start that I like I always like
getting bomb box at the beginning
okay we're just gonna send that over
there so they have more HP than me at
the start
that's always unfortunate
all right we need to get rid of that
bomb box
and he already he destroyed our
s there we go all right bomb box is gone
atmospheric charm is on its way over but
I think it should
ah of course
I'm gonna say I think it should okay
he's he's getting something ready
something big ready
I was gonna say
all right so we use the nebulous to
protect us a little bit
Cassandra absolutely wrecks the monster
book oh this isn't what the book said
all right we already got Hermione gone
that's good that's good
only with another atmosphere charm but
we're gonna have Pixies ready I'm gonna
wait just a little bit on the Pixies
we're about to get our first Death Eater
but so are they
atmosphere
just protect her from that
all right we're gonna get our Death
Eater right here
so today
take out that
wait he used his Ivy to take oh oh
that's really good for us
that's good for us too he used Ivy to
take out okay I gotta stop talking I
don't know why I used Ivy to do that
I think I'm just gonna
the cats man are so hard to get rid of
all right now we got two Death Eaters
he's about to get you get two as well
though
go ahead and throw the thunderstorm as
well okay you just use Ron
that was a good use of Ron right there
oh
all right we gotta get rid of the Death
Eaters
there we go they're gone
okay we got a big Advantage but this is
definitely not over definitely
definitely definitely not over they
could make a comeback here
this might end it right here though our
thunderstorm because they don't have
seems they don't have nebulous so
running out of movement
there we go
all right good start Good Start good
start
so see it's kind of like we wasted the
potion you know
because now the potion's gonna wear off
but it did help us play a little bit
lacks you know
all right let's figure out how many wins
we would even need if we're getting
about 35 points each time
how's it going oh that's right it's
about it's you got to get to sleep huh
oh Paula you're in um you could still
add me yeah yeah you can you can add
people as a friend I'm I'm pretty sure
even from different servers you can add
as a friend
right am I crazy I think you can add as
a friend
yeah good start good start crucio all
still one of the few spells that I don't
have all right let's calculate this real
quick
so 7 500 minus 7144 okay that's 356
divided by let's just say 35. so we have
if we went on a 10 game winning streak
we would have it
but if we have some losses in there
which I guarantee you we will
because it is
it is Diamond rank so you run into some
tough players now
but um so yeah roughly
roughly 10 matches if we were perfect
oh you think it is region locked
kind of unfortunate I wish they uh
yeah I don't know how I feel about all
that like it's weird that you can't
you can't add across regions I mean I
get it for like the Social Clubs and
everything like that and I guess it's
just to manage like lag and everything
when you're playing with other people
but if there was like a toggle or
something where you could say all right
so again we're at an HP disadvantage
this is like a common theme
all right so they're going with
Cassandra as well
oh I hate dealing with the fiend fires
hate it hate it hate it
all right so here's we're gonna try to
do knock this in here
oh come on come on come on come inside
come inside
there we go Cassandra deals with him so
well
like she just wrecks them
we almost got his Cassandra down too
look at that man she just
evaporates them so good
oh
I probably shouldn't have used that bomb
probably should have held that
all right so we saved her
I'm gonna wait I'm gonna wait I'm gonna
wait we're gonna use Hermione
that should take out Cassandra right
there
you got Arcus under two okay we got our
first Death Eater
Death Eater on the field
oh get it dude the Death Eater man when
they get going
so they used Ivy to take out our
Hermione so that's their second
companion
they're going with another fiend fire
and right now I'm just keep the pressure
on
keep the pressure on
go Death Eater
yes big Damage Big Damage Big damage
oh he's trying to he's trying to heal
he's trying to heal the uh the fiend
fire
oh my gosh we have another Death Eater
let's freaking go
oh my gosh
that was good incendio really good
incendio
okay Ron all right
all right we just gotta focus on him
I don't even
all right let's bring out Hagrid
we got two fiend fires right in front of
us
oh this is bad man this is bad this is
bad this is bad
we've gotta we gotta kill him
oh my gosh what a comeback dude
we were we were destroying that guy
oh I should have prioritized the fiend
fires a bit more
all right minus 25. there we go
a whole nother side of retro Mort right
yeah I've got crucio available today too
I don't think it's work I mean Crusoe is
a great spell but 30 000 gold like
especially if you're gold is so
important for leveling up your your
character and leveling up your spell
book that I decided not to do it
especially while I'm playing as as free
to play
once I you know if I actually start
putting some money into this game which
I I don't mind doing to support the
developers because I think it's a really
good game
but right now I'm just trying to stick
with the challenge here of uh
of seeing if I can reach Grand Master as
a free-to-play player I hate it when I
don't get bomb box to start it's kind of
unfortunate
okay I thought they would use nebulous
that's why I'm gonna have the monster
book ready
what in the world
healing yourself okay
oh it's one of those players dude it's a
Nevada cadaver player all right so if
they get three
insta kills with Avada Kedavra then they
can one shot me I have to be very very
aware of that
very aware of that
they're trying to set it up again
see look look all right that's two
that's two
together
oh
Ron just got melted dude
oh my gosh
the Death Eater
oh no that's three man
we gotta watch out we gotta watch out
we cannot get hit by AK
oh nice all right so if you're wondering
why I'm I'm moving around a lot more
I don't want to use all my movement
cards but
we also do not want to get caught by
Avada
yeah I see it's Insta insta Insta insta
come on in here grop
come on
they did it
we had
we had every advantage that's that is so
hard to do what they just did
I didn't think it would work with
inflatus
Sha
oh so then yeah then I'm just hovering
there
yeah that's that's why it's it's really
strong against when you have someone who
uses a lot of summons like I do
should I have the card I just don't use
it see look each opponent unit defeated
by the curse increases its damage by 25
percent
but wait as soon as this goes away here
after defeating four opponent units the
curse instantly defeats the target it
hits
super powerful
but you have to defeat like if they used
it on me at the beginning you know it
would do really good damage but it's
definitely not gonna take you out
but they had killed four things with it
gosh dude
I should have kept moving around I
wonder if I was in the Hagrid if I was
in the Hagrid bike
anybody know that if you're in the
Hagrid bike
does it take you out or does it just
destroy
the motorbike
oh
that is so annoying
never yeah that's what it does man
that's that's only the second time that
someone's ever got me with it
there's I've ran into several people
that try
but usually I'm just able to overwhelm
them like like that person right there I
mean we had almost completely
overwhelmed them
and it doesn't matter like level does
not matter
I love it when I get the uh okay that's
a weird start but okay
another weird decision but okay
it's all right come on bombs do your
damage
oh come on was that actually stuck on
that little
yeah
probably gonna take Cassandra out I
don't have nebulous anymore
well it actually didn't take her out
yes Death Eater
let's go
all right reset reset reset
no I didn't think you had nebulous
together now
foreign
Death Eater all right there we go
do not want to lose three in a row man
do not want to lose three in a row
I'm so nervous
just a bike Angie says oh okay I will
remember that next time
I could have hopped in the bike against
that uh the person that was running Vada
that would have been so helpful
that would have that would have kept me
because how much how much does Avada
cost
is it six
but yeah there's a lot of these lower
level players who are trying to make it
up the ranks using Avada because
if they can set it up you can be super
low level and you can still instantly AK
the opponent if you're good enough six I
thought so yeah
atmosphere tone
okay atmosphere charm to start
and we also have a Bellatrix player
I'm gonna save it
okay using Ivy to take out Cassandra all
right
Cornish Pixies
they should take out Ivy right here yep
now I did take out our bomb box which is
a good play
I don't think he had nebulous though did
he
Good Hits Good Hits
all right we should get our Death Eater
first
yep there we go
I need to move away from it
come on Death Eater don't worry about
the Box
go get him
I wish you could like guide the Death
Eaters
come on no take him out
all right here we go Hermione lightning
it's gonna get rid of Cassandra
hopefully all right he's got his Death
Eater
death eater's gone
all right we got about a thousand HP
Advantage right here and a full MP bar
you gotta use this
take out his bomb box
thunderstorm might just be able to end
it right here
come on Death Eaters
Death Eaters can be so unpredictable
not bad not bad not bad not bad
all right the main thing we have to
watch is this this Death Eater otherwise
there we go
yo Dylan what's up dude
we were just talking about you
welcome in hope everything's going well
dude keep us posted
Mrs rack and tour in the house as well
welcome in
all right back to back back to back
let's go let's go let's go
I'm gonna try to save the big draft of
peace
for if we get closer like if we hit if
we hit 7400
I think that'd be a good a good time to
use it
and you need to hide behind the summons
yeah that's
I don't know why I just got I got two
Lacks
and then I guess even if you're uh even
if you have um get hit by something like
inflatus you could still be hidden
behind
yes good to see you Dylan
all right monster book right away
so let's send you
which you hear all right they're going
with Cassandra as well
which they had a slight HP advantage
oh I don't have it
nebulous
okay you've got nebulous
darn it
I just wasted it man
all right we're gonna get our Death
Eater
that's our only hope for turning this
around
we gotta deal with her too at some point
come on we've got to get Ron out of
there man
finally
all right so remember they have nebulous
so I'm gonna wait a little bit till I
can throw the monster book as well
there we go
Monster books ready
I don't understand that dude like how do
they How do they
[Music]
I can't throw anything
Cornish Pixies
I'm actually okay with that nebulous
there
because now everything's focusing on yep
wait oh he's running a friend George
no way you hardly ever see people
running those
he just got the same one
go ahead use nebulous yep now it's gonna
take out your dragon
come on Death Eaters get in there dude
bro Death Eaters aren't doing anything
Cornish
he's still got so much health
oh my gosh dude we're out of moves too
dude Fred and George man
extra companions right there
oh my goodness
on the right track we were we were for a
bit
all right I think it's too early to use
another potion because I think I only
have one and one now
oh I got three let's use another little
one
so that's gonna protect us if we lose
this one
most of all though I mean it just gives
you peace of mind it's like okay
if I if I do bad this game doesn't
matter
that was a tough one wait is this
I've played this guy before
yes I love when I get bomb box to start
and we actually have a slight HP
advantage
do not see that much
oh wait nebulous
dude
the worst possible
oh that was a great nimbus
oh this is
that was definitely a win for her
that first little uh
flurry of action there
oh no that was a misclick
Cornish Pixies all right everyone that
was a misclick
that spell man
all right go ahead and do your nebulous
oh not doing nebulous
I'm surprised
now you did the nebulous
come on Death Eater
you gotta turn the battle for me
come on Death Eater do something
it keeps getting hit
[Music]
oh
my gosh where are you getting this MP
what that's gotta be a Hermione
well good thing we used the
I've played that person before
wait here
yeah legendary Hermione
I was thinking man you just are
constantly casting spells
they had so many thunderstorms that
match sheesh all right well we don't
lose anything
double clicking bomb box the best you
could do with them increases your
reaction time yeah I just like to put my
bomb boxes in a certain place
Christian gamer how's it going Cloud
Roth welcome in
Alicia you're sitting there playing
Skyrim
see I always like to uh I'll give you
guys a little insight
I try to have enough
you don't want to have the bomb box too
close to Cassandra
and then I don't want to be standing too
close to either of them so it's almost
like you want them to form a triangle
that couldn't get caught by incendio
oh my goodness this guy have a was that
a level 19 bomb box
Ed I'm pretty sure I saw a level 19 bomb
box dude
which is absolutely insane dude
why does nebulous not protect her I
don't I don't get it see look he's
standing too close
I'm gonna get some free damage on them
orb of water nothing I can do I don't
have my
the spell I need for it
all right everyone we're in this
beginner now okay I'm gonna wait I'm
gonna wait I'm gonna wait I'm gonna wait
now use it yeah I don't think we're
gonna win this though
it's all right the Lightning's gonna
take out your dragon now which is good
it's India
all right Cassandra's gone
dude I never have expulso when I need it
never
oh we got another Fred and George
how is that Dragon still up man
I bet his dragon's super high level too
that's the only explanation
oh my goodness dude the Fred and George
combo today
what is up with that
get rid of that bomb box
get some hits in on him
Cornish
pink explosives
awesome nebulous
Cornish Pixies
all right everyone oh dude
oh my goodness what was that was that
three Cassandras
oh was it only nine I thought it said
19.
oh my goodness
dude what is up with all the Fred and
George's today
in my whole run replay failed
I mean I could count on one hand the
number of Fred and George's that I've
seen
legendary
yeah it's just a level nine level 10
opal eye level 10. monster book
level 10 Ron level 10 Malfoy gang
sheesha
oh well we're still up on the day
we are still up on the day
[Music]
yeah I hardly ever see Fred and George
though but that was that was some
Bulgaria rank three maybe today is not
it guys maybe this is a bad time to be
on
we've had a rain we've had a couple
we've had a rank one
from some country that was a rank three
right here
and look at this 33 26 to 30 55. HP
difference
come on protect her good good good good
good good good
that's good
that's good we at least protect her
also
yeah get him Cassandra get him
get him
nebulous
no nebulous okay
let's get info to know
go Pixies
Sandra's gonna wreck the monster book
for him
all right about to get our Death Eater
dude Pixies with the bombs
they usually do a decent job on the
Dragon
oh nice nice incendio right there
oh no I messed this up
I wanted thunderstorm with Hermione
that was bad
that was really bad I had probably cost
us the match
Cornish Pixies
nebulous try to get a little bit of HP
back right here
oh dude if we could have got a
thunderstorm from Hermione right there
that would have actually been huge
we need the Death Eater to take out the
oh no no no take yes yes take out the
Dragon
oh a crucial
first time seeing that
Oh I thought that was gonna get it
all right now I think we're officially
uh
you went up against full 18 cards oh my
goodness
oh that's crazy
uh developer welcome in it is blue
Stacks you can uh read more about it in
the uh if you use my affiliate Link in
the description it actually goes to help
out the channel
it's a free program so you can check it
out give it a shot I also have a video
up on the channel That is a full
breakdown of how to get it running on a
PC
because there's a lot of steps you have
to go through
all right we'll drink a solo draft of
peace right there
performances lackluster for you oh
that's unfortunate
it's the only one that's been solid for
me
I tried a lot of the others and this has
been the only one that I can get
it to run well
there's a lot of steps though like you
have to make sure you're
you set up virtualization and make sure
that you're running it as administrator
and there's a couple of other windows
settings that you want to make sure you
enable
s
oh dude we are playing almost the same
hand I think or same deck
of course
to help you all right well companion and
companion are gone
monster book
anytime I see a bomb I'm just like
instantly sending the monster book
s
oh no
all right so we got a crucio player
I knew how did I know you were gonna run
a freaking opal eye
how did I know
all right I need I need it to hurry up I
need it to hurry up
and we knocked him out of orb that's
good that's good that's good
we're gonna have any shot here
the freaking opalized man
Cynthia
fantastic bomb
Cornish Pixies
you're stuck
I wonder if I should wait for the
lightning I think I should I think I
should I think I should
get in there Death Eater get in there
get in there get in there get in there
you took out both of them though
dang that's unfortunate
we had a shot he got both and he's about
to get his Death Eater
yep there he goes
Seconds
come on thunderstorm wait what
what did I die to
wait what
I wish there was a way to like skip
ahead when you watch the replay I don't
oh wait you can fast forward
I am so confused what I died too
overtime
wait is that a thing what that's
actually a thing
are you serious
spiders
all right let's do times four
your HP automatically decreases so when
it what is what is overtime like after
three minutes
no okay hold on we're gonna get a new
how did I not know this
well at least we had our potion going
that time
dude he definitely hit a couple crucios
that uh
okay I'm slowing it down look we've got
thunderstorm going
let's just go at normal speed because we
got it we got it lower than this
this right here was the game changer if
I could have got him out of exploso
before
well no it's not three
does my health start going down now
because it's already over three
oh it does
oh
my goodness
I waited for the lightning which is
probably the right call I needed to get
out of that faster
and I I cast thunderstorm and then I
thought going into my nebulous because
it gives me Health back oh they give me
plus four
and he's gonna hit that incendio
probably anyway but oh my goodness
okay all right all right all right
let's let's go uh let's regroup for a
bit I'm gonna go to the
I'm gonna go to my social club see if
anybody's got any trades so whoever has
lower MP automatically well lower lower
HP yeah you're gonna die faster
that is crazy I I cannot believe who
said that Angie
I have been I have been playing this
whole point
made it all the way to Diamond this
close to Grand Master and I did not know
I mean I'd seen the thing pop up about
the time limit I always just thought if
you hit the time limit it would just be
like
game over and whoever had the most
health wins
I did not know that
that you just both immediately start
taking damage wow so the nebulous play
was pointless uh because it wasn't gonna
give me back enough health I should have
went all out everything like everything
I can throw at the other person probably
should have saved up for incendio or
something
oh dude all right let's see what card
that I'm running
I don't have any purple ones so I can't
do anything with that
oh wait did mine expire for uh I was
trying to get some legendaries but it
may have expired I still don't have orb
of water
come on social club nobody wants protego
diabolica or the Norwegian Ridgeback egg
somebody trade me
but um let's see if there's anything
that I'm close to upgrading so Monster
books level 10.
okay expulso level eight I'm at seven
out of ten let's let's request put this
out into our social club
see if anybody wants uh let's see I'll
put all of these up for grabs
okay and then how many do we need we
need three of them okay so that's one
that's two right there I'll just do the
same general stuff
that's two
and then let's put one more up first up
for sale up for trade
one two three we'll do you oh we got a
couple extra augmentes I bet somebody
will take me up on that for sure
foreign
consider bringing a broom or obscures to
deliver Death Eaters close to the
opponent Death Eaters are not targeting
the wizard most of the time
well
I feel like the Death Eaters are just a
little unpredictable in general
broom or obscurus though
what's wait what's an obscurus
and I didn't know that a broom could
would actually even transport the Death
Eaters
oh I want to drink the draft of Peace
but I can't I need to save it
I need to save the big one for sure for
when we get above
we've got two one more small one and one
more yeah I can't use them we gotta
we gotta just hope we wake up
incendio what about incendio I'm using
incendio
yeah it'd be great if I could upgrade
that card and then I definitely need to
try and upgrade incendio as well oh I
should also start trading for some
nebulous
let me see if I can uh
I don't think I have any keys I think I
used them all up before I started
if you fly over when your Death Eater is
about oh right if you can time I see
yeah if you can time it right when
they're gonna drop in
yeah yeah yeah yeah
look crucial in my in my shop today
I don't think I have any Keys though
yeah I'm out out of keys I used a bunch
earlier
Jenny how's it going welcome in
just so the port key yeah I mean it's
been working well for me to this point
how I've been playing
like I said man some days you just like
you just get on a roll
and you just get rolling
Davey and welcome in uh thank you so
much
appreciate you becoming a member here on
the channel
enjoy your emotes you also get a special
role in the Discord as a as a channel
member
I think you became a channel member it
doesn't pop up and say you're a sub so
I'm thinking I'm thinking it's a channel
member
all right guys
we can do this
we can do this we just gotta get on a
streak
get on a big winning streak and we're
right there
house in the house what is up my friend
I'm not new United States rank three I
think it was 300 something 370.
371.
and they're on a three win streak all
right so we gotta try and stop their
streak
been a little up and down today so far
if you're just joining in guys we we won
a couple
I think we run like a three four game
winning streak at the beginning now
we've lost a few
people
oh come on
oh you got all the tricks I'm not new
don't you
know you got all the tricks huh
come on back up
yep right there
nah save it save it save it save it save
it
yeah go ahead go ahead go ahead
this isn't what the book said
dude the thunderstorms
oh my gosh that exploso was so freaking
well timed
thunderstorm
s
monster book
now you're interested
dude
It's gotta be a Hermione
ER how how many thunderstorms has this
person used
like this is this is actually insane
oh what a great incendio
what a great incendio
are you serious right now
oh
dude the Death Eater was about to change
that fight man
it was that fight was about
to change oh wait I wanted to see if
they were Hermione they had to be a
Hermione right yeah
amount of uh
thunderstorms that got thrown there
oh my goodness
GG what's up welcome in
another hunt
Tennessee this person ranked two in the
state of Tennessee
what
the potion makes you rank against
counter decks I that sounds like a myth
that sounds like one of those things
that somebody somewhere said and people
just started believing it
but it's not actually true
yeah that was a bad play by me
Cindy
Magica
oh my gosh the freaking opal eye
fantastic bomb
nebulous
swellings
let's wait for thunderstorm
s
come on Death Eater yes thank you
bruh
bruh take out that bomb please
Cynthia
dude
just constant incendios man
gotta move away I gotta move away gotta
move away
Death Eaters blast him
no
what are they doing they're just they're
standing right there they're
dude sometimes like some of the clips
I've shared and posted in the video
sometimes the Death Eaters I mean they
just
they just walk up and just absolutely
melt with crucio and then sometimes they
they do that
sometimes they're
like they're they're standing there just
just looking at him
looking at him
we could have won that we should have
won that uh
oh my gosh we cannot drop below 7000 you
guys I can
I need to walk away I can feel it I can
feel it happening
like some days I I start playing and I
and I got it I'm in the zone we're good
we're rolling other days
this is I feel like it's one of those
downhill days man we can't let it spiral
we we gotta take control right now
silly Death Eaters right Tim right
oh my goodness
try getting Grandmaster in the first
week got to 7400 no
oh I'd be so sick
okay acromantula as a starter
oh okay this is a little bit different
quite sure don't even bother monster
book we gotta take him out
I'll use incendio if I have to
send you
dude he's why is he so strong
there we go Leaf get out of here you're
zero
Cornish Pixies
we gotta take out the niffler now
now
all right Death Eaters get in there dude
single Death Eater right now
oh his twins they're stuck
they were stuck behind his uh
oh that was that was actually really
good
get him Death Eater
real just another one
oh my goodness dude he was
bad all right we already got two this is
really good start
see Death Eater do that to him
if you're in the Hagrid cart
all right you're out
I don't have a bomb box coming up oh we
gotta use something though
see if we can get another Death Eater
he doesn't have nebulous so
look at that look at that see that Death
Eater knew what was up man
Dropped In
immediately started doing its job
it's definitely a win thanks GG yeah I
don't know what was going on with that
it was some odd plays odd plays but you
know what I'll take it it's diamond we
got to get back above 7 100. Joe what's
up dude welcome in
so wait who was that that said uh Roxy
did you did you ever make it did you
ever make it to Grand Master
you were all the way at 7
. and then uh let's see how said could I
make a video for
uh for deck building for the forest yeah
yeah yeah yeah
I definitely want to I've been so
focused on PVP and if I'm able to get to
Grand Master I'm gonna make a video
about this deck right here
but I want to be able to make it first
I have so many video ideas that hinge on
oh this is good we're very closely
ranked 230 269 us player
so many of my next videos hinge on
whether or not I make this
because I just feel like you know
okay I gotta Focus gotta Focus sorry
guys
put Cassandra over here
I don't like her being that close to the
bomb but he used
accio kind of messed me up
dude she dude she tanked that like a
champ
are you serious right now
I hate it when I don't have a bomb box
on the field
okay this is good though
I should have saved that bomb that was a
big waste
see do you have nebulous
you may not I gotta get back in here
Cassandra take out him take them out
take them out take them out look at that
dude
she's like I got this
want Death Eater
up
it's like whenever they hit them with
their basic attack it it breaks the uh
all right now you got your Death Eater
Oh Cassandra though let's go
come on Ron come on Ron take Ron out
take Oh Cassandra still lives
well she did for a second
what you do have
what the heck
he does have nebulous
what's that about
why did he not use it I guess he just
didn't have it at the right time
no Hermione don't cast nebulous
all right two Death Eaters on the field
it feels like I'm up a lot more than I
actually am
uh bad and actually no no no decent
incendio decent incendio look at that
there's the power of the Death Eaters
ladies and gentlemen
that's what they could do
yes when they're like paying
they're like they're just like the Death
Eaters in the books you know
what are they good for man
just always screwing things up
oh dude
that was so funny
but when they're on when they're on
their game like that they walk up they
got a clear Target
a clear Target in their sights
you see they just melt
they just melt
Ben snow says nebulous is useless what
what rank has been no offense
it's definitely not useless right now
because uh thunderstorm is going like
crazy in in PvP
Stacy would also love a video on oh we
played this person earlier oh my gosh
wait was this the this might be the
Avada cadaver player
no no no it wasn't but we were up big on
this person and then they came roaring
back if I remember correctly
they came roaring back and just made us
very sad
made us very very very very very sad
what was their deck though I can't
remember anything about what they were
running
okay they're running the stack
oh
get rid of her
oh orb of water all right let's move up
come on wiggle around
come on Death Eater go go
zap him
yes yes
get a little lightning going
look at that though
the spiders just the spiders absolutely
wreck the Death Eater that is so funny
man
that is so funny
that spiders destroy oh it was a fiend
fire guy
dude why is he just now using fiend fire
this is how he came back though remember
the fiend fire
fiend fire really did some damage
come on come on come on
dude how do you kill this thing
there we go
I mean I've learned my lesson man
from now on
whenever I see one of those on the field
and you want to try and avoid killing
the other things that's why that's why
this guy is running spiders
because whenever you kill them it like
feeds the
incendio On The Stack
come on Death Eaters
keep zapping
keep zapping him
all right
turning it around turning it around guys
let's go that's three in a row three in
a row
I don't think we've hit have we hit 7
200 today I don't think we have
all right let's see if anybody's uh
anybody in my social club
if you guys need some cards go and see
if you have expulso to trade me I'm
three away from being able to upgrade
this card
being able to upgrade it would be nice
help help boost my probably not going to
boost me up another yeah definitely not
going to boost me up another level but
all right
I need big tips for solo exploration of
the forest solo is tough the solo side
is really tough
I think I'm on level
twenty I think I'm on level 20 21
somewhere in there
but yeah it's like because you need a
different deck for every
not not a completely different deck but
you do need to tweak it based on uh
what the specific objective and what the
specific enemy is now one thing you can
do is you can watch videos if you
haven't seen that little thing with the
videos you can see other people who've
completed it you can even copy their
decks see what they were running
that's why I love using dartmagic King
of the North you need the deck oh yeah
yeah I'll show you here
it's pretty strong everyone who has
spiders plays fiend fire right for sure
winning streak coming I hope so that's
three okay we got the Brazil rank 258.
you're on 19. 19 is a really tough one
GG
19 is really tough
all right fellow Gryffindor
I salute you let's do this
I hate when I don't start with uh
with bomb box have I mentioned that
now you're in trouble
all right we gotta get them inside here
actually that one's almost dead
come on get in there with Cassandra yes
zap him zap him zap him
okay unfortunately she is almost dead
let's try to heal her up a little bit
while he's occupied over here
ladies and gentlemen we have a Death
Eater on the field
Death Eater just worried about Japanese
cats though
one cat at a time no not Cassandra dude
I'm gonna prioritize the monster book
oh no see look it's gonna zap me
see whenever they spawn right on you
they're just they're just like insta zap
then if I get up close like this
they're not so scary
I'm backing up from you dude we're about
to have a thunderstorm
all right we have a slight Advantage but
I don't like I don't like how I'm
playing like this I don't like the flow
of this match right now
I don't know how you could see me Ron I
don't know
oh you've got an opal eye
bro
oh my gosh Death Eater yes
feel the power of the deputy
man with the Death Eaters just zap the
dragon like that
how how is that that is so hype
now we gotta deal with them though
let's heal up a little bit still just a
slight slight advantage
that was nice
[Music]
dude wait how is Hagrid already down
Pixies
no way you're running crucio bro
how about this guy like hiding so many
spells here
oh that was a great incendio
we're dead
GG
oh
I told you man like even when we had the
advantage I just did not I did not like
the flow of that fight
didn't didn't feel good didn't feel good
just felt like I was barely making it
you swap request oh somebody traded us
we're close
we're getting close I think we just need
like one more yep one more one more one
more
crucio should I put in your deck uh PVE
deck absolutely
PVP deck
actually be pretty strong in certain
scenarios it's really good at taking out
anything big like
antipody and opal eyes
your Bellatrix Echo has three plus on
crucio well that's just not fair
I don't know why you gotta come gloating
about it
I'm just kidding I know the three the
plus three is super rare
but it it does happen I did not get it
on any of mine
traded another let's go all right we'll
upgrade that after this this was also a
very uh highly ranked player I saw
man we should have
that last one we should not have lost
that
are you quite sure
sendio
oh protego diabolica okay okay okay
dude give me the bomb box please
and we do know that they have nebulous
let's go ahead and use
oh he started moving we got lucky
we got really lucky
what
Hermione just ran through incendio like
it's like as nothing man
like it's nothing
brilliant I've got just the eye just
another one all right they're gonna try
to break out of it
come on zap zap zap zap zap zap zap
zap him Death Eater yes
it's very unfortunate that Hermione was
standing right there by the Death Eater
did I waste it
again I don't hi everyone I don't like
the flow of this fight man
actually let's use that because if he
does if he does nebulous
oh he didn't
and I am not stuck in the orb okay
oh dude we gotta start using some stuff
we're wasting MP
why did I walk through the incendio dude
oh one dead theater did not get caught
oh my gosh this is too close I don't
like it
bro
yes
oh my gosh
those are the kind that I lose a lot
oh
okay deep breath deep breath
oh my gosh he was oh he was turning that
around
he was really turning that around
hate it when you match with a teammate
wait who doesn't have a single spell
oh like they're running all uh summons
leave two of them on HP and they can't
finish no
um
that's crazy
whenever it gets that close you get so
nervous and spam everything
I mean I'm getting a little bit better
at it at not doing that but
it is definitely hard to resist
especially when the HP is so close
you're just like damage damage damage
damage damage damage damage
you've got to damage them
yo swamp witch in the chat Mia welcome
in I don't think I even knew your real
name
Alan kevis
Alan let's go dude
can I go back Jake I I can't we're
trying to get to Grand Master I gotta
Focus up
no bomb box
slight disadvantage on the HP starting
off with a nebulous okay bombtastic bomb
we heard it
see I was too close I shouldn't be that
close to her
all right you go get the monster
look
all right here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna back up into here
oh I wasted the exploso
because the lightning plus
Cassandra just wrecked that opal eye
and sometimes I feel like I just don't
get the cards that I need at the right
time
like I need the freaking
monster book
see look at that the the Pixies plus
bombs they do decent on the Opel eye
zap
oh you misplayed that
I mean I guess no not the niffler
go after him
oh Death Eaters
go ahead do nebulous do nebulous
oh I actually kind of wanted him to do
nebulous oh he did he did he did he did
bro how is Cassandra still alive
try to heal her up a little bit
man he took her out that's fine that's
fine
zap him Death Eater zap him
oh he faked me out right there
come on zap zap zap
oh I wait I used it too early
oh this is gonna be close man
I don't like
I don't like the oh the opal eyes is
gonna be tough
it's probably the last set of Death
Eaters we're gonna get
oh no
all right oh what
how bro how
come on Death Eaters come on come on
come on come on come on come on
oh he's out of moves he's out of moves
no the
no the oh my gosh you guys
I gotta figure out a way to
I need like I need something that goes
off in my ear
no
we had him
oh geez why is there a timer anyways
three minutes come on
what a ridiculous time
oh geez
legendary hey Timothy ninja what's up
also King of the North how's it going
Ali's uh good night good luck with
Grandmaster thank you thank you
it's not going well so far I mean it's
not going bad but it's not going like
well either
Columbia ranked 10 player coming up here
oh my gosh the Bella deck is so fun but
I love uh I like Hermione and Duos
all right we actually have a slight
advantage
all right you got a nebulous we'll
remember that
all right basically free damage on all
that
no that missed come on
bro that should not have
dude I love freaking Monster books just
like what nebulous
I don't see nebulous
I probably could have preserved some HP
right there
and uh resist the urge resist the urge
Where Are You Gonna appear
Ed
nebulous
oh
I thought we saved her
book
oh my gosh that dude with the incendio
he keeps forcing me to move
I don't care about the Portis
thunderstorm was over
yeah see look at this man like he's he's
coming back thanks to
nice Death Eater nice
okay we still have Hagrid as well
he's got I think he's got like two
health
oh my gosh here we go again dude
the Reed
that was not a good broomstick right
there
not a good broomstick
I just had to time it just right I know
the path he's gonna come right back
there but um
AJ draws what's up dude welcome in we
opened up a second one so you can join
we've got two now so it's it's house
actually let me type it in the chat
it's House raconteur 2 like that no
space it is all wait why did it not type
why did it not type
are we still live oh there it goes it
just took a second so it's house Space
raconteur 2
there's the two just comes immediately
after the r
yeah it's uh Mary Mary is the captain on
that one Mary Studios yep yep
house racket two I forgot about that
Timothy that's what we should have used
because it is case sensitive so I wanted
we wanted a space after rack and tour
and then the two
but it hit the uh character limit
that's also why I'm not retro raconteur
in the game all right man we haven't
been able to crack like 7200 yet today
Nikki how's it going
update is there an update for the game
or uh for something else
oh man that was a good one Gigi that was
too another nerve-wracking one at the
end
Felipe from Brazil right 282 I think
we're right in there for U.S 222.
all right man some good games today so
far some close ones
some bad ones some good ones all the
above we've had it all here today so far
oh I do not like this start at all in
terms of cards
a little bit right here all right let's
go ahead and see if you have nebulous
you do okay
why am I taking damage
bro
why was I taking damage
I don't understand
no no no
I I don't understand why we were taking
damage right there
oh wow look at this little play
that's nice
okay that time they used expulso
I don't like it man I don't like it
all right everyone
nice okay that's really good that's
really good
you just use the incendio in Hermione
all right we might be able to turn this
around
maybe maybe maybe
not gonna be easy but
we're at least in position now
thunderstorm go ahead yep
no don't walk through that
No Death Eater oh that's unfortunate
another Hermione
the freaking thunderstorms
we had it though we got it we got it we
got it we got it
dude thunderstorms is a hundred percent
I'm calling for for the bands next week
in our region it's gonna be orb of water
and it's gonna be thunderstorm
that's my prediction
Let's see we can get you in the social
club through Discord sorry I'm just
going back in Reading
what I missed here oh a small update
yeah that's right they did have a little
bit of an update
you got Draco mouth white nice Malfoy
gang's pretty good discount humor
welcome in uh they've been a little up
and down but right now we got a little
two-game streak going 71.85 trying to
get to 7 500 as a free to play player oh
I forgot to uh that's right Damien
traded me we can upgrade our exploso
right here that's gonna help
let's go taking that up to level nine
very nice very nice let's see what is
the damage on exploso it's pretty low
but
it's mainly used oh that upped it to 82.
I feel like it used to be just 60 or
something
and I wanted to see oh what was it I
wanted to look at the damage on
wow incendio does 168 total
42 four times
it does have a pretty good range too
do you guys even know about these these
little stickers here
proficiency details
increase proficiency to unlock stickers
and if you hit this
you can like put these little stickers
on the page here so like if I wanted to
put this one here it's kind of like that
and then let's see I don't want to cover
up Hermione over there
I'm just gonna say I'm just gonna leave
it at that and then it like it's your
little sticker will show up over here
mid man how long do you expect the new
Social Club to have available spots I
actually haven't even checked to see uh
to see what we're what we're looking
like right now
but yeah the first one filled up pretty
quick which shout out to those in our
social club we finished like 30
34 overall 39 somewhere in there
and the vast majority of us knew nothing
about the game there were a couple like
Draco and maybe one or two others who
had been playing soft launch and knew a
lot about it but most of us were totally
new and I did not expect us to do as
well as we did man but we got we got top
100 got those rewards secured
all right so let's see we've got two
I don't want to burn our potions yet
I definitely want to try to get to 7400
before I use the big one we've not been
able to crack 7 200 today
but um yeah so discount humor they've
been up and down a little bit
up and down we started off okay then had
a little bit of a
downward spiral now we're trying to get
it going again
trying to build a little winning streak
when we first started we calculated we
needed to win about 10 if we won 10
games straight we would have been Grand
Master but of course I never expected
that to happen
all right so we've got a we've got the
upgraded esposo now nice this is my
favorite start right here
when you give me both of those to start
I love it
what you're playing Ron at the beginning
no way
no way they just played Ron like that
and they're not even afred and George
that was weird
they got a lot of HP though man they
might just be like really confident
because of how
level they are
and yeah let's go and use it
come on protect her
yes it actually worked
get out of the way so they can't use
incendio on both of us
zap that
oh yeah this is somebody who is over
confident because of how high level they
are
just another exam
s okay
India
come on Zach Hermione
no
annoying it's okay
atmospheric charm man I took it out of
my rotation for right now
but whenever Norwegian Ridgeback comes
back probably gonna have to add it again
Now remind me I don't think they have
I don't think they had nebulous
no great incendio
I should have moved man I should have
moved
that was a really good incendio
all right we gotta deal with the Death
Eaters and then if we deal with them
I think we got this one
all right there we go Death Eaters off
the field
GG
all right that's three let's go
three in a row three in a row three in a
row
and does that put us over 72 yes it does
all right man all right all right all
right
oh hey we got a key let's go
oh what do you get if you get all the
way oh here's what we're playing for
guys this is what we're playing for
Grand Master dual nameplate welcome to
Hogwarts proof of an excellent dueling
performance for the welcome to Hogwarts
season grants a unique display on your
personal page higher tier name plates
will replace lower tier ones
whoo
are we going to kick in active players
oh good question house so
I want to be open to everybody
because I know some people aren't going
to be able to know life this game like
some of us
so our our primary social club I want to
be like active players people who are
playing at least every week most of us
are playing every day but then the
second one I want to be a more casual
group that it's not as much pressure but
yeah in our main one if we see that
people just like aren't aren't doing
anything or only getting a couple points
then then yeah we'll ask them to move
over to the other group and then we had
a couple people join that had joined
from like seeing us on YouTube and
probably don't even follow the channel
regularly and so we started removing
some of those that's how we freed up
some spots in our main group
but yeah I mean if we have to open up
multiple Social Clubs we will if we have
to open up even more
you think it'll be full by then does it
show you
what it's at right now
all right let's go for four I was
tempted to use the uh
the single draft of piece right there
but
oh wander we played wander before
I think we lost
I think we lost to wander
man I wish I could remember what they
ran
what did they run
oh my gosh look at the HP difference
yikes
[Music]
closer
Cornish Pixies
Bro Look at Cassandra
watch her work man
she's like oh you're gonna throw out
that too
Sandra is just ridiculous I love it
all right we weathered the storm and we
get the first Death Eater good good good
good good sign
good damage good damage
I'm Gonna Save that I'm gonna use that
though
All Right Here Comes Your Death Eater
no way
took a little more damage than I would
have liked to from that Death Eater and
then oh wait oh wait Ron's not down
all right this is bad man this is bad
that could have changed the fight right
there
oh
we're down big
monster all right I'm saving up for
Hermione
right here
this is it man this is it we gotta turn
it around right here
zap him zap him zap him zap him
a book said
come on get in there
yes dude
you can always come back guys you can
always come back
four in a row let's go keep it rolling
keep it rolling
oh man it looks like it's going so slow
right back in right back in right back
in
right back in right back in
yeah I'm almost positive
do you prefer Mia or swamp witch
I keep thinking of you as swamp witch
I'll call you Mia probably prefer your
actual name right
yeah I feel like I'm running into a lot
of these players where you can tell
they're just like super high level
they've upgraded a lot of cards so they
get really overconfident
even when they're higher level than
somebody
and they think that they can just keep
relying on that all right so we got a
level 10 thunderstorm to deal with
[Music]
um
slight disadvantage on HP
not bad
oh dude I did not know that an exposed
so immediately takes them out
I mean I'll take that damage to even
things up
all right they're saving up for
something though
told you
oh thank goodness Hermione did not get
another thunderstorm off
potato diabolica okay let's do this
I don't want to use monster book yet not
while she's got that going
I'll use that though
then we'll use monster book
no
oh and it Oh I thought it took out the
Death Eater too
that would have sucked
all right everyone oh using Ron on that
okay okay okay okay okay okay
come on get him
all right there we go
okay so let's go Hermione
gotta get her out of the nebulous
no
I'm not just gonna let you sit in that
anymore nope nope nope nope nope
not gonna do it
not gonna do it did the Pixies get hit
by it because they fly
foreign
why am I still getting hit by it
the Dead
all right well we had a good Street we
had a good streak
only lose 24.
Still Still gain more
we're right back in though we're right
back in
feels so bad when you lose because of a
missed Acura Expelliarmus oh I know
right
you starting up some duels Joe let's go
Ecuador rank four
oh man
might be time for more uh caffeine here
in a bit
guys hope you're enjoying the stream
today appreciate you all hanging out
if you're new here we stream pretty much
every week you can catch us here on
YouTube sometimes and also sometimes
over on Twitch
bro everybody is running this
everybody
want to get a little bit closer there
you go
oh this isn't what the book said
get closer
explosive
thunderstorms
bro
that's all we're running into right now
if you're wondering why I throw these
out because it at least helps helps to
spread around the damage
it keeps me and Cassandra from or keeps
me really from taking it all
like I don't know about that incendio
they seems like such a waste
oh I should have used Hermione
all right everyone we're in this
together all right it might be better
that I didn't use Hermione
thunderstorms
how many okay we've got another Hermione
player dude how many freaking
thunderstorms is this guy gonna run
oh my gosh big time Big Time big time
come on we gotta wait we gotta wait for
the lightning
and then he's gonna do this yep yep yep
yep yep
it's gonna be close man it's gonna be
close we were already leaving that's
good
I freaking hate thunderstorm right now
oh it's so close it's so close dude
bro these games are so cool close
they are so close
Joe what do you play mostly do you play
uh do you play Duos or you like running
solos
on your Hermione deck your record on
thunderstorm is five what do you mean
like
like throwing five in Rapid succession
oh it's so it's so difficult to deal
with like even when you have nebulous
now everybody is just uh
they got a port key or they got expulso
or they got incendio
man I wonder if uh like I wonder why Ben
says nebulous is useless I mean I don't
think it's useless if you
if they don't have anything to throw
then it's it's a big help because you
can just chill in your nebulous while
the thunderstorms going
all the whole match
I thought you first I thought you meant
like in Rapid succession
foreign
because like if with Hermione if you
have it if you've got like 10 MP
and you use oh man we just played this
guy and we should have won but they this
is the one that beat us
and they used I think this was another
like crazy crazy thunderstorm user right
add you in the club
oh you'll house you I think you have to
request to join
I think you have to request it I don't
know
slight Advantage here in HP
I'll get you through this
atmosphere
pretty even pretty even pretty even
he's wanting to take her out
come on get that niffler
come on
no don't walk by me he's just gonna
incendio us
I told you
maybe able to get both of them for a
little bit yeah
all right in Cassandra that is so good
for me
oh that was so good
all right everyone
wow protected Cassandra
look oh he's mad
he is mad
dude why are you just now bringing out
the Opel eye I don't get it
about to go
come on come on come on come on come on
that's big that was big that was big
that was good
we just need to hit him with like one
thing
like that
wow we've really improved against him
that time I don't know why he didn't use
the dragon more
it's the dragon is so difficult to deal
with
AJ you just got your legendary Bella
Echo right
oh it's so
it's so good when you get it
you're almost a 7 300.
okay come on come on come on one more
win let's go
let's dive in there just go straight
right back in right back in
right back in
Joe you've been doing solos you don't
feel very supportive in Duos just yet
I just like man I did not expect to love
the dueling in this game this much I
didn't expect to love this game this
much period but
the dueling is so ridiculously fun
I appreciate it AJ congrats on that
Bella Echo too
that's what I've been running in PvP and
I just so happen to get that as my first
legendary Echo is perfect the cards
weren't great
but it was my first one so I went ahead
and upgraded it all the way and then I
got I I think I have three up on the
cards that I use I have three boosts
bomb box which is obviously perfect to
have
um oh my gosh Afghanistan rank four bomb
box Pixies and then Cassandra are all
boosted with my with my echo
all right slight HP Advantage for them
they are running Bellatrix ontastic bomb
we gotta take that out
Sandra go to work go to work go to work
nice
I need a bomb box though I don't like I
don't like this let's just do this
all right get the bomb box out
he's gonna use that on the bomb box of
course
Cornish Pixies
Manny he just he won that exchange huh
he's got a big Advantage right now
oh my gosh
how am I getting hit
did you guys see that
where did the where did the uh
is it lagging or something what is going
on
isn't what the book said I did not see
the the
oh that was great incendio
Pixies yeah this guy
that bludger's low-key kind of annoying
isn't it
how do we not have anything out on the
field
look at that there goes the bludger
all right fine you can deal with
lightning
gonna make me run around the Dodge a
freaking bludgeer
nice zap him please
let's freaking go dude
oh I got so many things to use
I'm gonna say that bludger won him the
game
no
oh that bludger man that bludger was so
annoying
because you have to keep moving like
anybody know is there a way to knock
them out of bludger
is there a way to knock oh and they got
their blood shirt level 11 too it did 2
000 damage to me
guys that is actually insane I've been
underrating this card
2 000 damage he used it four times it
did more damage it did double the damage
of thunderstorm
Shah
yeah they do have to move too that's
true
I wish there I wish it was kind of like
orb of water though or something where
there was a way to knock them out of it
but I don't think there is I think they
can just keep
doing it
unless I guess orb of water would
definitely if you got them caught in orb
of water
thank you
make a video on how to counter the
dragon the the opal eye or the because I
made a video on countering the Norwegian
Ridgeback
but yeah opalai it's good to have aerial
units
that's for sure crucio is a great
counter to opalai
great counter to have crucio
oh we only lost 14 for that let's go
that must have been a high level player
if you finish haunted hollow level 10
you can choose yes
I'm nowhere near that high yet
you know what the old magicians say you
can hide from Thunders into the fog but
you can't avoid a fire tornado
that was tough that was tough I can't
believe how much damage that bludger did
though over 2 000.
I guess I try not whenever they have the
bludgeon on the field I'm moving around
so much
and it throws me off Italy ranked 42.
hey we played this person earlier Alpha
I cannot remember if we won or not
oh yeah we did we did clear level eight
I thought it was uh I thought it was
much higher to choose your own Echo
though
but maybe I'm thinking about something
else
what are we doing here buddy
okay there they've got a lot of
oh that this was you
no way you were the protego diabolico
one
why am I taking damage
isn't what the book said
I wasted that palmtastic should have
waited a second
important
it's also
all right go get in there get in there
get in there
do they have
nebulous
trying to remember
they do okay
come on bolts
oh how am I caught in that
Cornish Pixies
yes
that one Death Eater did not die from it
let's go
Joe what's up welcome in you just got
the diamond using Hagrid fiend fire deck
dude fiend fire I feel like people have
kind of slept on that one
but I've been running into some tall
fiend fires lately
oh man okay
I'm trying to figure out how we're gonna
use these potions guys
so I have one draft that will protect me
for three matches from dropping the rank
that's the big one I have another little
one that will protect me for a single
match
we just crossed the 7300 threshold I'm
for sure holding the big one
for when we hit 7 400.
because I think that would be that'd be
the perfect time to use it to give us a
cushion a three-game cushion
because if we're at 7 400 and we win
three games most likely we got it most
likely
unless we're
you know right at 7 70 400 exactly you
know then we wouldn't we wouldn't get it
with three
but
should I use the single one now
jzt welcome in what is up I know I owe
you a message jzt good to see you here
today
and Jay-Z by the way I don't know I mean
I don't know if you want to talk about
what you and I were talking about
privately but if you want to talk about
it in the chat too man we have a really
super super awesome community that I'm
sure there'd be a lot of people willing
to help if you if you felt like letting
people in the chat know
oh David welcome in new here good to see
you David thanks for stopping by guys if
anybody else uh hanging out is new here
we post videos here every week on
YouTube We stream sometimes on YouTube
sometimes we stream on Twitch so if
you're not yet subscribed here make sure
you subscribe we have a lot of Hogwarts
Legacy videos on the channel and also
here lately we've been covering a lot of
Harry Potter magic awakened which I'm
having an absolute blast with right now
you are in the middle of watching my run
to Grand Master we are at 7314.
and we need to get to 7 500 to reach
Grand Master
so just a little bit under 200 points to
go
and we do have two draft of Peace
potions
that we could use at any time one big
one small
I'm thinking about using the small one
right now actually
right now yeah I did uh I have beat the
main story yeah through year two anyway
they haven't brought out year three yet
what you're trying to figure out is
switching modes affects your ELO if like
if you lose a match in Duo
no no no no no now if you do hit a
certain rank like I hadn't played hardly
any Duos
and then when I hit diamond
I went over to Duos and it like gave me
this pop-up and said okay because you
made it to Diamond and solos we're at
least bumping you up to platinum I think
I was still like gold or something maybe
even silver because I hadn't played very
many Duos so it will bump it up like
that but it is separate like like you
see right here I'm 73 14. if I hop over
here into best partners
see I'm only 54 or 13. now that unless
you're asking about maybe there's
something behind the scenes that we
don't see
could it be maybe
I'm not for sure
when will London come out can I add you
back on Discord no Jake I don't accept
friend requests from everybody because
the uh the I do that to keep my private
messages down because if I accept it
from everybody I would have so many
messages
but yeah just feel free to tag me if you
need to ask me anything
you work in mobile games and the ELO
matchups track your wins losses
right but do you think
oh I see you're trying to figure out
if you lose a match in duo will it make
your next solo match less difficult ah
okay so you're asked you're asking for
something a little bit deeper than what
I was thinking I'm not sure
so for instance if you lose six in a row
you're gonna be more likely to get right
right right
so you're saying like if you went over
to Duos and lost a few then and you hop
over I don't know
oh man you guys what do you think what
do you think use the potion
I'm gonna go again I'm gonna go again
if we win this one I will definitely use
the the small potion definitely use the
small potion
North America ranked 235 1A I'm I'm
almost pause I've played against one
before it's so funny how you start to
recognize these names
oh we got a crucio user it's a level 10
. we got to be on the lookout for that
Annabella tricks with a slight HP
advantage
just go ahead and put Cassandra back
here to deal with the
monster book for us
give her a little bit of protection from
that
oh man that's bad
get the cats out just to help spread out
the damage
no that missed Hermione oh that's such
garbage
there we go
fantastic bomb
brilliant I've got more time for
Preparation yep I know you're about to
try and throw uh
oh there's an atmospheric charm on me
come on he's over here
no don't die to it Death Eater
how is this thing not dead
he had one HP I wasted the exploso
but monster book
almost even he definitely has the
advantage
that's fine I'll let it take out the
Dragon
oh
bro I might need to add back
go get him
you're a wizard Harry
get close get close
get close
no he was hiding them
dang it dude
thank you guys so much for for the new
member there oh my goodness in inks
staloman
so sorry I'm sure I'm mispronouncing
that inks Inca stalman
erden Batar
that's probably incredibly bad
incredibly bad thank you so much for
becoming a member enjoy your emotes
there
oh man we let one I feel like we let one
get away right there getting the three
Death Eaters was just too much and we
had no movement
we had no movement
all right win or lose after this one I'm
gonna go get
another
I'm gonna get a Cherry Coke Zero this
time
gonna refill up the water
and then we're gonna be good to go
then we're gonna be good to go
Italy ranked 42 oh my goodness we
already played Alpha
think we beat Alpha I think we beat
Alpha
but I'm not sure we've had so many I
think we might have won one lost one
against Alpha
I can't believe this you guys we're
getting so close
dude where are my bombs
come on come on come on come on come on
come on come on come on
dude Kevin with all the health in the
world
Cornish Pixies
that's fine go take him out please
what
all right just calm down calm down calm
down calm down
oh he switched it up he was not running
a Snape earlier
Hey Jake gifting out
a membership Jake thank you so much
appreciate that
welcome to Gryffindor
yeah I knew that was gonna take her out
oh man this Snape deck is really
interesting to deal with
thunderstorm
nebulous
oh I
that explosive actually helped him
come on blast Cassandra what are you
doing
blaster
Blaster again please
gotta preserve our movement here
oh we had to burn the incendio that's
good
there we go
there we go Jay gifting out a sub to Mia
or a membership I have to remember
it's called memberships here
memberships here on the YouTube uh me
and now you can enjoy those emotes in
the chat
you also get the special role in the
Discord
also get discounted merch if you guys
want a retro hat like this we also have
a few Wizarding World themed items in
our in our merch store
can you brew the thing that you did so
you don't lose rating yes yes I already
brewed as many as I could before we
stream before we uh
started running today
it's called the draft of peace
it is this one right here
I don't know where I got the larger ones
from because I don't even I don't even
have it unlocked yet but
it might have been from
I don't know a reward from something
yeah so I'm still hanging on to one
small and one big I'm saving the big for
when we hit 7 400.
if I win one more I'm gonna use the
small
if I win one more giant stranger I know
we're so close we're so close
we got the potions ready
this is the highest we've been this is
the highest we've been today you guys we
started out
what do we start at guys or just a
little bit above seven thousand
oh man this person
this person dominated us last time
we had we had what looked like a huge
advantage
and then they just like turn the fight
around like crazy man
okay this is the preferred start I love
this start
this is my favorite start by far
get in there monster book
oh it was the protego diabolica player
that's right
oh man this is tough
dude the Pug no man are you serious
right now
thank you
I can't remember if they had I think
they do have nebulous
all right everyone oh this is actually
good
my turn
isn't what the book said
spread out spread out spread out
I can't see them
from
bomb
no way that was a great incendio
rate incendio
oh that's such an annoying play style
man
my gosh it's so annoying
I guess I should have just saved up
every incendio
guys he ran into them two giant stranger
oh
I thought I had it I really did I
thought I had it once I had once they
burned Hagrid and then I still had
Hagrid
[Music]
dang I thought I had it
oh we've played one a earlier too can't
remember if we won or not
oh geez I think we lost to one I think
Juan yeah Juan had the crucio
well
a monster but fantastic forms
oh you're the old boy
nice got some damage on the opal eye
there that's good
come on Pixies go to work
bro how's that opal eye still up man
take out the opal eye
sheesh
like that may have been a waste but like
I gotta get her money out of there
I cannot risk getting hit by another
oh my gosh it's still up
kind of a waste there too but
don't really have a lot of a choice
brilliant I've got just the idea
what was the AFK
I think you win AFK
I think you went AFK
what the heck
dude I'll take it
I'll take it
man
after that last one I'll take it I'll
take it I'll take it
yeah yeah you already know you already
know stranger we
we take those yes we do
oh my gosh dude if we could win one more
I will use that first potion
oh wait I said I was gonna get another
drink didn't I
here you guys want to watch the replay
actually that one wasn't that great
let's watch uh let's watch this replay
against Alpha here
I'll be right back I'm gonna get a I'm
gonna refresh get a beverage
Cornish Pixies
sponsor
Ikea
[Music]
just another sound
foreign
oh yeah this was Alpha
exactly Jenny
exactly
that's why I like playing on my PC
because it's connection it's much more
reliable
hardwired in than on my phone
dude look at that he had the advantage
he was 11 20 to my 9 20.
Cornish Pixies
and he had Cassandra out
thankfully the Death Eater
gets Cassandra
I'm telling you man you gotta prioritize
the Death Eaters
I know he was trying to finish me off
but I've seen it too many times man like
people
the Death Eaters are they're like
oh what's the word for it it's like a
like a glass Cannon
their health is so low like
you hit him with a lot of different
things and it'll take them out
but if you if you let them linger oh my
goodness
they can just absolutely Shred
absolutely Shred
all right we've gotta get this Victory
come on
we've got to get this win
use this or get this win protect us for
one game after that with the potion
hopefully we win we win it anyway
when the next the next one after that
would be at 7 400.
oh my gosh you guys
so close and yet so far
trust me I know we could all come
tumbling back down like we could lose
everything why are we playing a grand
master what
no
we're just diamond
come on I shouldn't lose many points if
we lose this though how is it not one of
those top matches that gives you boosted
points or whatever
come on man let's see if they have a big
Health difference
ah slightly but not bad
I'll do the arena is different too
Cornish Pixies
how do I not have a bomb box yet dude
oh wow I'm like I'm so surprised to see
that
I can't believe like it's somebody else
running Hermione with the thunderstorm
oh this isn't I'm just like I don't know
are you guys like shocked right now
I'm in such shock
I'm moving too much
oh
they're whiz-bang player
we just got them to burn it right there
we gotta watch out for that inflate us
whizbang that's what they're gonna try
to set up
all right spread out spread out spread
out spread out
Cornish Pixies
always stop
on the bomb box
no way dude no way
oh no we got distracted man
just another example
monster book
still not over still not over
no
move
oh my gosh they're so dumb
oh that was a nice incendio
we moved why can we not move
oh
[Laughter]
um
magnificent
oh we missed
come on yes Grand Master defeated
let's go
let's freaking go dude
oh my gosh
whoo
Noob with the eight months uh what is up
Noob it's been eight months already
time sure does fly by when you're with a
great Community Noob dude thank you so
much for the eight months
it really does fly man it's crazy
it is crazy
oh my gosh you guys I'm so hyped from
that right there
all right we're using the potion we're
using the the single potion right now
so we're gonna drink that one the small
draft of peace that protects us right
now if we lose this game we will not
drop I really like if we get to 7400 man
and I can use the big potion I will be
so just like relaxed at that point
but we got to get to 74.
Paula you're telling me shoot
you're telling me
so many of them are close though it's
it's
I love the PVP in this game I really
love the PVP
oh you can't view details from another
server that's right
so they were running Hermione
how did they have more Health than me
because their cards were not that high
level
I mean 999
a seven three at a dog
[Music]
I wish I could see their spell book
level but I can't because they're in a
different server
because they had more HP than me but my
my cards were
see I got eight eight nine ten ten nine
nine ten
my companions are 9910.
so they had more HP but we oh they have
a little tin Hermione though level nine
Ron
oh their whiz-bang was level nine
they had a lot of level nines
he's a hacker report
hey the first time I ran into a Fred and
George
I was I was clicking the report button
so fast
I was like they used another companion
what
what I'm looking for the report button
and then I thought wait a second Fred
and George
don't they do something weird like
then I went back and saw remember when
you were just a simple dark lord newbie
Mort and found this place before
Hogwarts Legacy right
that's when it All Began for so many of
you in the lead up in the lead up to
Hogwarts Legacy we had so many good
times together
oh my gosh you guys they're gonna give
me all Grand Masters now
this is no
dude
why should oh my God
this can't be I'm gonna like exit out of
the game I'm gonna exit out after this
Cornish pixie monster book no bomb box
which is very unfortunate
oh they're a Snape
they're a Snape user
Snape is actually very strong against
this build that I'm using
come on Death Eater what are you doing
get in there
don't be afraid
don't be scared don't be scared
oh he's using the swelling solution to
attack faster
that's actually super interesting
and she would Snape every other cast
dude look at him oh this is actually
kind of sick I'm not even gonna lie
that is actually kind of sick man
this isn't what the book said
zapham Death Eater zap him
oh my gosh
get him
no
stay patient stay patient stay patient
stay patient
s
Cynthia
GG
another grand master
taking a seat ladies and gentlemen
taking a seat
whoa
let's go
you're running my deck
which one Jake the one that I uh the one
that I made the video or this this deck
right here 73
[Music]
I think that qualifies the 7400 I think
we need to use the big potion
oh my goodness that's two grand Masters
back to back
I'm gonna take a second though like why
why did we get matched up against two
grand Masters maybe the closer you get
it
it like forces you into it oh man
they're all from different servers
dude that's that was a crazy strategy
though
and kind of awesome like I have to
admire it oh and their time Turner is
only level seven as soon as they get
that time Turner upgraded level 10 a pug
no
yeah their cards aren't that high of
level
so you probably had a slight Advantage
there
you love how hyped I am oh man see I get
so uh
there's other companions Noob uh what do
you what do you mean like in addition
yeah there's right now they have uh
they have all of these over here
Harry Dobby Hagrid Fred and George Newt
Snape Hermione Neville and Bellatrix and
then I've heard they're adding I think
Luna is getting added
are you getting GM who are losing
I don't know what you mean by that
I mean like they currently have it so
you mean like maybe they're on a losing
streak or something
yeah I updated the deck since my video
once so the video that I posted about on
YouTube guys that one carried me to
pretty much to like Platinum Diamond
level
but then once I started hitting Diamond
I had to switch it up a bit
so and also you've got to pay attention
to the banned cards so right now the uh
the Norwegian Ridgeback egg is banned
so I don't really need atmospheric charm
that was my main purpose of having it in
there which it's still a good card to
use
uh also right now orb of water is
getting used like crazy so I added
I added a exploso right here to help me
with orb of water
that's mainly it and then I also added
so lightning and monster book of uh the
stack of monster book of monsters that
one's kind of a good uh
I could debate either one
but right now the Lightning's just so
strong especially if you run Hermione
boom Hermione lightning
if they don't have nebulous it's so much
damage getting thrown out onto the field
at once
so yeah this is what I'm running right
now
oh man I think we have to I think we
have to use the
I think I need to use the potion guys
I said when I hit 7 400. I'm going to
use the big potion well we're at 73.99
my goodness and we're at what 207 in the
U.S right now
this is the goal you guys this is the
goal right here Grand Master
I doubt we would ever be able to hit
does anybody know why there are two
magic awakens
is uh
is stranger still here I bet stranger
would know like I don't understand
is this one only for top 500 in the
world
then what is like what is the difference
1951 that person is so far in first it's
insane
Spellbook level 120 is all guys so yeah
I have no doubts that once
like Grand Master I think is possible
it's it's within reach
but magic awaken I don't think you can
hit that without uh without being a pay
player
Tim what's up we've got uh one really
active club we just start up a second
club which has plenty of spots left
search for house rack and tour two and
you'll find us house underscore not hold
on let me just type it
your YouTube video deck uh I'm not sure
if the stream's lagging or what Jake I
already I responded to that
so just like that right there
oh my gosh you guys okay I think I'm
gonna drink it
and let's see if we keep getting Grand
Masters
well that's just that's just so cruel
uh sorry galinator
we're on a mission right now
here we go all right we're protected
we're protected for the next three duels
we cannot lose any points for the next
three let's see if we have to don't tell
me we're gonna have to go through Grand
Masters every time to actually reach
Grand Master
we just we just had to beat two back to
back
pigeon
one is top 500 okay
gotcha okay a diamond but they're Spain
rank 43. all right well at least even if
they're really good I just feel better
knowing that we don't have to beat every
single Grand Master to to get here to
get to uh
to get to Grand Master oh I saw a Time
Turner in there I wonder if they're
another Snape
3381 pretty good Advantage for them
oh no not him not him not him
oh it is a Snape it is a Snape user
I need to put that over here
bro look at
the monster book still like doing work
magical
yeah I see you I see that your Snape I
see
it's like he thinks I don't realize it
Cornish Pixies
let's wait a bit
I'm betting you don't have nebulous
oh you do
it's fine take out that one
oh my gosh
this isn't what the book said still
close
it is still very very close
also
come on Death Eater what are you doing
[Music]
I went the wrong way that was stupid yes
let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
my highest win streak I think is just
like 11.
actually I don't know I think my highest
might be something in Duos
I was with uh Vero
Erv Aurorus the other day from our
all right so see we still have two two
free games guys two free games no zero
pressure
zero pressure games right here
oh great grand master Michigan rank one
this is bad this is bad I can't believe
we're running into so many Grand Masters
and we're not even in Grand Master yet
explain that to me
3408 to 300 3005.
interesting
I shouldn't have walked out with the ash
Winder
now you're gonna take her out huh
and we also got a Bellatrix
yeah let's wait let's wait let's wait
take out that book
oh the stack of Monster books hey
don't worry about that monster
go get him
yes yes Yes actually I don't want the
him yeah
yeah and zap him zap him oh my gosh
he's zapping him like crazy
dude that was some big damage
and we already got more let's go
let's go
oh that was a bad incendio The Bad
incendio got greedy
you can't get greedy man
can't get greedy
all right he actually weathered that
storm pretty well
he's about to get his Death Eater
oh that was really nice
Cynthia
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no
oh my gosh dude
come on blast him
blast him
yes
oh my gosh
another grand master down
shisha
but man he almost brought it back
oh my gosh one win
we are one win away we are one went away
and we have a draft of peace
we've got one draft of Peace left that
gives us two two matches you guys two
attempts to get this
oh man hold on
I gotta stretch I gotta move around a
bit
I'm gonna eat a chocolate covered almond
oh my goodness dude
I'm just gonna give give the matchmaking
a second
don't put us up against Grand Masters
anymore please
although we're a 3-0 against the grand
Masters man let's go
oh dude let's take a look at what that
guy what those cards were like
oh wow a ten plus two a pug no a ten
plus one
[Music]
thunderstorm you gotta be kidding me
nine plus one Hermione ten plus one Ron
nine plus two Pixies wow that's a really
solid
Bellatrix Echo there
they're actually in our region
dude they're level 51.
we're not even 40 yet you guys
that's what man I wish
I love this game so much if everything
was on a Level Playing Field and PVP
though
it would be so much more insane
in in a good way it'd be so much more
insane I'm level 38
witnessing greatness sending swamp witch
magic boost I appreciate it
in the words of the Queen Another One
Bites the Dust
oh my goodness you guys
all right
we've got two games
to win one
two games to win one
that's it that's all we gotta do man
74.79
we're on a five win streak a win is
guaranteed to put us in Grand Master
no if ands or buts about it with the
points
all right hold on I'm gonna I'm gonna
use the restroom I want to make sure I'm
fully here you guys can watch this
replay here
I'll be right back
atmosphere
Cornish Pixies
fantastic bomb monster book
stack of monster book of monsters
thank you
fantastic
Cornish Pixies
explosive
just another example
Cornish Pixies just another one down
fantastic bomb
s
monster book
dude he somehow like I had a huge
advantage
and he's still almost he still made me
sweat
right
look at that it was 2007
600 something
then he gets Ron though he timed this
really well look at this Ron plus his
Death Eaters then the stack
okay let's freeze this I was over 2 000.
he's at 660 something
he gets run out he gets two Death Eaters
he sends the full stack of Monster books
I get the explosive which oh dude and
then that one got
oh my gosh that could have been the end
right there
shisha
and then he get he got me out of Hagrid
so quickly
I'm just like let me get some health
back let me heal a little bit
and then the thunderstorm just zapping
all my Death Eaters are gone so now we
know the fight's not going to be decided
by Death Eaters now okay this right here
I had a decision to make man
I had a decision to make
we got the Monster books bearing down
but I see he's at 387.
I fire the incendio with him what do you
think was it worth it knocked him down
to 121.
I hit him with an exposed so he's down
to 17. now I just need to hit him with
anything I don't know what he oh he died
did the time finally the time worked in
my favor you guys
oh finally it worked in my favor
all right ladies and gentlemen get your
popcorn I'm gonna give everybody a
second to get back from the break
get your snacks get your popcorn
get whatever you need
because we got two matches to reach
Grand Master we got two matches
we've got a draft of Peace active right
now
it has one
vial left
Gigi I'll get my sandwich
Mia warming up some gumbo let's go
on a five win streak right now
let's do it let's do it folks
here we go
all right we're playing with house money
if we lose it's no pressure
then the pressure ramps up oh dude it's
taking a while it's having to look
worldwide I bet you it's gonna try to
pull a grand master
I bet you it is not gonna put us against
a diamond
oh it's taken forever it knows the game
knows
it's like oh you're trying to make it
oh Diamond Japan rank 474.
okay all right all right all right let's
see what kind of deck they're gonna be
running
if we can figure it out
oh man none of the cards popped up
all right they have a slight HP
Advantage it's not a Bellatrix deck
dude why'd they run out of the nebulous
like that
no not the orb
it come on get Hermione
all right
it's all right it's all right it's all
right
a pug note
fantastic
oh it's her mind it's a Hermione
for sure Hermione
with all the thunderstorms
come on go in there retreat
zap him yes
come on don't stop
don't stop Death Eater yeah zap her too
oh go in orb of water that's bold
yes
this isn't what the book said sendio
come on Death Eaters
awesome
oh no get out of there get out of there
get out of there get out of there
no no no no
oh my gosh it's dead even
thunderstorms
let's go
let's freaking go oh my gosh it was so
close
wow
oh they almost pulled it off dude I
thought the epugno is gonna do it for
them
oh my goodness you guys
hold on hold on we gotta find we gotta
find something hype in here I don't know
surprise me
wow I don't think this is too hype
what's up
[Music]
hold on
okay okay
this is better this is better
Grand Master
free to play Grand Master ladies and
gentlemen
free to play
screenshotting this
oh man
I got some videos to make now dude about
our
about this journey
yo thank you guys Elwyn Trisha JP GG
Jake Paula
didn't even need the draft of Peace
that's right we went on a six game
streak to get it
[Music]
wow
I would have been so sad if I lost that
dude they they played a great end game
right there
they played a great end game thank you
mid man appreciate it I know I want I
wanted to get it so bad as a free to
play now I I will probably spend some
money on the game I will because I love
the game so much and I I do want to
support these Developers
I'm not a fan I'm not a fan I'll just
say that straight up I'm not a fan of
how it affects PVP I just I wish it
didn't
like everything in PvP should just be
level like
maybe make it so that you the cards
could be paid a win but like don't don't
have the level differences and I know
they try to match you up
with people that are you know close to
the same level
oh my goodness you guys so there it is
there there was our
there was our deck that that got us here
that's the deck that we used
whoo if anybody wants to try it out for
themselves
incendio monster book bomb box exploso
Cornish Pixies
the cats thunderstorm nebulous and then
our three companions Cassandra Hermione
and then Hagrid
White Mamba thank you AJ thank you
appreciate it
King of the North you just clipped it
hey let's go
hey send me that clip or you could post
it in Discord or something like in the
magic Awakening Channel
if you don't mind
oh man
I am so I am so relieved you guys I
wanted I've been wanting to get this for
weeks and I was so I was so down the
other day
I like I said I think it was Tuesday
guys I it was like an all-nighter I I
pulled an all-nighter
and just like went to Rock Bottom
I was almost all the way back down to 50
5800 or something
and then I started really paying it I
was really beating my head against the
wall because if you looked at the people
I was playing they all had such higher
spell books their cards were way higher
than mine
and so I said you know what let's go do
some forests let's go make some trades
for a bunch of cards shout out to our
house racket to our social club guys
coming through with all these trades I
know a lot of you helped me get uh there
were some trades for the monster book
there were some trades for the cats
I think somebody traded me a Cassandra
Pixies and then several today with
esposo it was huge couldn't have done it
without you guys man could not have done
it without you
shout out to RNG in the game for giving
me the Bellatrix legendary Echo
which came in clutch
let me tell you came in clutch let me
download this right here save that image
oh my goodness you guys
draft a piece has ended and we're ranked
165 in the US
let's go all right let's see what we got
out of this
and then three cards I don't use but I
don't even care
don't even care man
I can just chill now
what do you guys want to talk about we
guys want to talk about what a moment to
tune in white mama I'm glad you're here
so glad all you guys were here who got
to see that
that was Epic Man
that was epic I'll be honest I haven't
streamed a lot when I've been doing PVP
because I'm so nervous that I'll be
terrible on stream which
the last time we streamed it I mean we
weren't bad but we weren't
we didn't go up at all we hopped in Duos
and did pretty well in Duos but
I can breathe now man I could rest easy
and now I'm I'm pretty much under no
illusions that uh I don't think you can
make it much further without without
paying you know paying something what is
this little thing right here unlock the
global duel to match up with other
students from countries regions and make
it onto the world rankings ah okay so
you have to get to uh
what is that that's around like 8 200 or
so
Wow Let's go see if we unlocked anything
else like did we get uh
I saw something pop up about an
achievement
your space is pretty cool oh like this
little space right here I haven't done
anything with Myspace
I haven't done anything at all well I've
done more than this it just
wait
it's just taking it a second to load
view achievements
oh there was another dueling one how am
I only 70 dueling oh I I never did the
20 in a row
what do we get for that that was a
background or something
some kind of background
bumping up in Duo sometimes takes a
delay but it should take you up to
Diamond oh I think I actually I I hit I
hit Diamond Mia I hit Diamond
um
yesterday with I think it was just
playing randoms
and I made up to Diamond I was so close
when you and I were playing I was like
right on the edge but yeah I already I
did hit diamond
new challenge win one Duo duel I mean no
I
I'll accept but I don't I'm just kind of
I'm just gonna chill for a little bit
you guys
chill I did not mean to hit the space I
want to get into my knapsack
and I also want to go to uh Madame
malkin's dude why does she never have
anything else for me to buy
she never has anything else
it's always the same stuff
every time like sometimes actually I
think that one on the end
what do you guys think looks like me
this one has been the one that I'm like
leaning toward I haven't bought any
clothing yet at all I like this one but
I wish I could do a different color
you guys know if you can change it
excuse me the color on that
because these you can only get if you
already have redeemed it on the mystery
wheel
which I would rock that one
if I uh had the choice
oh yeah but what I wanted to do I want
to look at my knapsack
and I want to info right here
dude we did it as a level 38 too
we did it as level 38.
all right so how do I unlock
Supreme best partners
I think for that one you have to be
oh man how do I get that one
I want that
I thought we for sure unlocked a new
did we not unlock a new uh
oh wait it was it's the background it's
this this right here
oh sorry Jake I don't I'm not gonna do a
dance right now
oh it was these yeah yeah yeah
I think that one is the one that I got
for
is it that one I wish it would tell you
where I got it both of these are new
I kind of like this one better
oh my goodness you guys I gotta tweet
hold on I'm gonna tweak this out
oh and I'm gonna get that clip from you
too
who was it that said they posted it
house
or uh
no it wasn't house
thank you for whoever posted that I'll
see you here in a second
I will see it here in a second
King of the North let's go dude
oh you got the you got the screenshot
nice we need the uh I need to get the
video of it but I don't know if you can
can you even do that on
on YouTube I know you can after the
video has been like uploaded
you're level 39 but still silver and
solo
you'll get it you'll get it
I need to open up uh Retros dueling Club
Retro's dueling Club
yeah I mean we could we could do the
replay here but I'm talking about so I
can like share the link on social media
you know what I I will just share the uh
I'll go ahead and crop my screenshot
there
I can't believe we we did it without
even needing the draft of peace
that's actually crazy I mean sometimes
that peace of mind means everything
just having that peace of mind
just knowing in the back of your mind
that hey if I mess up it's not gonna
hurt me
we actually did that quicker than I
thought man I was planning for it to be
a pretty uh
pretty lengthy stream if things started
going downhill but I also had to prepare
on like
backing it like you know stopping if if
things were going too poorly
because man I will tell you this Gigi
and anybody else who's
trying to uh really
move up the ranks
if you start losing I would put a cap on
it like I would say if you lose three I
would say three in a row
that would be my the number that I
decided on if you lose three in a row
then it's probably just not your day
go maybe go and do something else and uh
and then come back another day upgrade
your cards
Grand Master as a free to play player in
HP Magic
awakened
let's go
and then we're gonna put the screenshot
with it
dude I'm so excited man
I'm so excited
so tell me what kind of videos would you
guys like to see on the channel
about like me moving up through the
ranks because I have some ideas
already but I want to hear what you guys
would like to see too any specific tips
or I know we already had one request
about dealing with the antipody and opal
eye dragons
yeah
I need a good Emoji for like excited
oh wait hold on maybe oh I'll do the
wand emoji
wand oh wait
magic there it is
do it like this wand space Grand Master
space
there's an art to this you guys there's
an art to it
boom tweet
tips on Forest solo
to ever a kill and welcome in I I
haven't hopped on Hogwarts Legacy in a
while since my trophy
since my platinum trophy finally popped
and came in
I have not hopped on it in a bit
but as soon as they drop something new
like surely there's going to be DLC at
some point right
right
no wait that's not what I want to do I
want to go to
Forbidden Forest
I'll show you a little trick GG I don't
know if you know about this or not yet
it's like if you go over here
look at this little icon down here this
video icon
so if you hit that it's going to pull up
all actually I don't know
if it's recent clear I don't know how
they they pull these in
I'm not sure what exactly goes into it
but
it will show you some clears of it and
it'll show you their level
which
crazy that it's that high
and then you can actually watch the
video of them doing it so like I'm at
level what is this I'm up to level 23
right now
and it they've I think the lowest one I
see here is 46. so like we could watch
how they did it here with this Hagrid
deck and this has helped me a lot
Kellen we are playing this we're
actually playing it on PC
but it's using an emulator called
BlueStacks we are a BlueStacks affiliate
if you guys want to try out BlueStacks
it's a free program
check the affiliate link down in the
description below so we've been playing
it on this whole time and then I do
occasionally play it on my phone as well
Kellen like when I'm uh
in bed at night and think oh man there's
one more thing I could do the dancing is
really hard on the this so I do the
dancing on here
and then there's one one little mini
game that doesn't work properly on the
for a class
on here but they're eventually going to
bring the official PC client to
everybody
which one is it that you were having
trouble with GG by the way all right
oh you watched a few maybe I'm getting
trouble with my poor strategy or
something I have no clue was it 19 is
that the one you were on
oh you can go through multiple decks
with different echoes
on that free on that little video page
dude how does this person win this zero
six Beast defeated and look at their
health
they're about to get zapped again
orb of water which I don't have
come on social club members check the
trade page trade me orb of water I know
some of you have an extra
I know somebody out there has an extra
one
still zero six beasts to feed it only I
am super curious to see how this ends
still zero six okay time is expired
wait what
okay they got one defeated
somehow dodging the dementor
oh my goodness that was actually crazy
you can't even get past solo stage 16
mid man
King of the North if you had an extra
you would it's all good I'm just giving
you guys a hard time
well you don't have any tokens Jenny
didn't you get one
you should have got one from our
our social club uh rewards I thought
and you can also buy them not not real
money did you know you can buy them with
uh
how I bought them
I bought one through the thank you notes
so if you run
if you run with a group
oh it's down here yeah see I already
bought mine for the month it's sold out
it costs 50 of the thank you notes
so every time you run for it forest with
a group even after you've gotten your
rewards you can actually keep getting
I'm not saying this just to get you to
trade with me I'm just saying it so you
guys will be aware because yeah those
legendary ones are pretty hard to come
by
so you can get one by using these notes
but then you can also get one
from if you go here into your social
club
let's see we'll run around in here
run around for a bit if you go to the
card trade
and then see up here
oh no wait you can't on these can you
you can on these you can use these uh
what are they called Club crests
you can use those to buy these but I
guess you can't use them on that or
maybe I already
no because that one says sold out
so yeah I don't know how I end up with
two
so here are the current trade proposals
okay
see look I'm offering up
uh this one why can't I think of the
name of it potato diabolica
or diabolica and then also the Norwegian
Ridgeback egg
offering up both of those
which I think actually have uh oh no I
did I used I upgraded my thunderstorm
looks like swamp which is looking for
thunderstorm
dude look at all you guys already with
your uh your level tens
trying to get it to level 11. I see an
insert name here I see you swamp which
trying to get them up even more
can you free room with other players on
the game sort of Kellen it's it's
not completely open world but watch this
like if I actually even in here
I can like see other Live players
well sometimes you can
hold on if I go to if I go to the
Hogwarts the castle skies you'll
definitely see there's always people
flying around outside the castle
what I wish they would add as a feature
where well hold on so let's fly around a
bit here
controls are kind of weird because yeah
see there's there's somebody right there
oh yo it's Jake
Jake what's up dude
there's Jake right there flying around
and then see if we recognize anybody up
here
I don't think so
who do we have here their names are like
blurring together
so yeah like you can run into people
but then like if you wanted to do an
activity so like let's say we wanted to
run the forest with some people you have
to go to the force and invite them there
same thing for like duels you go and you
then you invite them in
and then if I go to uh
like if we go to there's some places
around the castle as well
like the Great Hall I bet we'll see some
people in the Great Hall
you have a token but no extra or gotcha
oh yeah I was gonna show you I was gonna
watch the video GG sorry I'll watch it
to show you to talk you through how I
did did that one
yeah so like there it's it's free roam
to a point
but it's not oh
inspect
but it's not just totally open like
Hogwarts Legacy or something and it has
a lot of loading like see I can't just
go in there
It's gotta load the screen
all right let's go back to the forest
we got it Roxy we got it
we got it
we used uh we actually won six in a row
to close it out six in a row can you
trade across servers
I'm still not totally clear Noob on what
because if you can be in the same Social
Club then I'm pretty sure you can trade
with the person but I think if you're if
you're not in the same Social Club then
I don't think you can trade at all
you can only trade within your Club yeah
all right GG let's do this let's look at
oh yeah the Sorting right here
card level approximation
that's pretty cool so you can see like
the lowest ones that have cleared it all
right GG stuck on 19. this one had me
stuck for a while as well
let's see if I can remember
how I got through this one
I think it was a Hagrid deck
let me watch it I'm having trouble
remembering which one exactly this is
I know Noob I wish there were certain
features that it would let
oh this was the opal eye one okay the
good thing about anytime you have poison
on the ground
try to choose aerial units
so things like the dragon right there
can just go crazy
now they weren't running swelling
solution but swelling solution might be
a good good one to do as well
now you
and then anything like companions
anything that's going to help draw the
attention away from you so like The Fray
twins right there oh Norwegian Ridgeback
I didn't run that one
I definitely ran the opal eyes though
because ridgeback doesn't just fly it's
I mean it stays on the ground
oh Noob you had a spare one oh man
yeah I wish there were certain features
that they would enable a like cross
across different servers
but I guess that's just how these games
have to work I don't know
yeah this is sort of
sort of strategy I use but not not exact
ly oh dude that Norwegian Ridgeback
though is tearing it up over there look
at it
right here
yeah the the ridgeback has a lot of
health so it almost it almost that one's
almost destroyed
now you got two opal eyes on the field
with about 30 seconds left
and then they're both gonna go to work
on that one
yeah I was throwing a lot more spells
down too like I haven't seen them do
many spells
like I was throwing a lot of incendios
whiz-bangs to help out
and then I think I used bomb box too
you really want the opal eye but you
only have the Thunderbird for air oh you
don't have the opal eye yet
see I forget that like because the way
the cards work
sometimes it's hard to get like I don't
have uh I don't have crucio yet but I've
gotten two Avada kedavres of course
Magicka welcome
Magicka how's it going we just hit Grand
Master
now I'm just chilling
I'm just relaxing hanging out with you
guys
hanging out with you guys a little bit
before we end the Stream
Jake said for for me to go to the dorm
yeah let me go and Jake is one of my
Gryffindor roommates
let us go to the main tower
it's probably about time we clean up
isn't it Jake
I haven't cleaned the room in a while
thank you so much for becoming a member
Amigo appreciate it
it really does mean a lot it goes to uh
help out the channel you also get emotes
unlocked you get a discount at our merch
and then you also get a special role in
Discord and whenever we do game nights
which we need to do we actually need to
do a game night really soon
I think it's about time for another game
night I'm feeling like everybody loved
the
oh what do they call Jack box games dude
excuse me like you gotta sit right
you're blocking my view oh wait I came
to the common room I didn't even come to
my dorm room
heiress black
copy what in the world
what is copy
but yeah Amigo appreciate that very much
thank you
okay why what do I actually do to to go
to my room dormitory there we go
you can tell I don't actually go there
very much
maybe start putting the name of the
second Club oh good call good call good
call
yeah cause I don't think I have that
hey
wait is this actually you like live Jake
let's take a look at your deck see what
you're running
oh you got that crucio nine plus one
nine plus one
that is you in game that's so cool man
a robo Panda was online two days ago
Robo Panda where you at
Dylan Dylan is out right now you guys
Dylan is expecting his first child
in real life not in game okay let me
clean up this trash over here
we cannot not clean that up why can't I
clean that up I'm trying to clean
your Arkansas rank one oh that's awesome
dude I played against uh I think I went
up against Tennessee rank one earlier
and I went up against
Michigan rank a a very high rank I
didn't enable my state maybe I should
have but
when it asked me that I just said to not
display that one
I'd love to see what I am though
I wonder if you can still see
even if you chose not to enable it like
what what rank probably not and you
can't change it until the next season
that's all right though that's all right
I mean did I already do my daily tasks
for today I think I did
look at Jake's like let me let me uh
have my moment in the camera here
yo Anthony what's up welcome in
Harry Potter movie night
man we get we'd get copyright copyright
strikes
or you just mean like in it in Discord
hanging out or something although I
don't think Discord really uh
allows it officially
oh you can see in the titles I'll I'll
have to remember I'll check that later
you can play the pianos
yeah let's go I'm gonna walk around uh
let's walk around Hogwarts for a little
bit
I really haven't explored this game as
much as I would like to I know there's
like Secrets around
like little uh
you know little things that are going to
give you gold
like this right here
sometimes you even get cards
oh wow that was pretty solid right there
let's see anything else in the library
Anthony you missed it dude we hit Grand
Master earlier
we hit Grand Master guys as a
free-to-play player
now we're just relaxing I'm just like
I'm just calming down now coming down
off that high
dude it's so hard to nav the camera's
kind of a little wonky on PC sometimes
that all you can find in here no other
secrets in here
oh I know there's got to be another
Secret in here some oh I see it I see it
I see it
what do we have in there
I have more gems 200 gold
I'll take that
it showed them all it only shows the one
oh it only shows like the yeah like I
think I have mine set to the United
United States one
oh wait is that something over by Lottie
no
all right let's check let's check the
Great Hall
actually I don't think I've ever really
checked the castle corridor
yeah the fireworks show was so cool
I wonder if that was just a Fourth of
July thing or if
what the heck it was just literally
right there when I walked out
was that just a fourth oh more right
here seriously
guys if anybody's just tuning into the
stream now uh the Grand Master portion
has ended we made it
we made it to Grand Masters
as a free-to-play player it is official
it is in the books
oh you want to do muzzle studies let's
do muggle studies I haven't done any
hold on I'm gonna look and see if
there's anything hidden in here oh I
knew it
I got 17 seconds Jake 17 seconds
can I find anything else in 10 seconds
come on camera the camera's not turning
for me yes there's one more eight seven
six four I miss counting three boom we
got it
all right muggle studies
foreign
if you're still here what kind of deck
do you run
I've been looking forward to muggle
studies all day I made it with uh
Bellatrix
now that I'm getting higher I'm gonna
have to start learning another deck
because I've heard I think I don't know
if it's when you hit magic awakened or
Grand Master where you have to have
other
they can ban your deck so you can't use
it you have to use something else and
then you can ban one of their decks
I think I'm gonna try to main Hermione
for my second
it's my second Main
you know you can skip this Jake if you
push uh if you just click
but if you haven't seen it yet
my point is that all the lessons you
check your ranking in the dueling area
oh that's
that's right but I don't think you can
once you it actually had this big pop-up
that was like once you say no
you can't change it for another season
by teaching you about Muggles we can
foster understanding and create a more
inclusive Wizarding World
a more inclusive Wizarding World
oh here we go
transportation is the fastest uh
airplane
oh you can see what they look like okay
okay okay
on the ranking page in the dueling area
gotcha
it's not a common muggle athletic team
mascot or clumps
whoa I was the one who got that no way
how do Muggles use hoses
they talk through them
they drink milkshakes through them oh my
gosh imagine
oh you can't skip that's all good Jake
it's fine
which of the following would seem out of
place in a muggle neighborhood
tabby cat reading a map
a child selling lemonade I don't even
know what the first one is
a crop with a docked tail
which instrument allows Muggles to
examine objects that are too small
microscope
[Music]
what should six of ten
when did the first motion
what
okay it's not b
not a c
oh
I don't know why it lets you see other
people's guesses even the opposing team
that's so strange to me who or what is
the lawnmower
a machine that cuts grass
thank you Anthony yes it was very very
exciting
very very hype stream that we made it
which is along is not an appropriate pet
to give a muggle
definitely an alligator although some
people
some people you know man
some people like having alligators
the little baby ones
who or what is an emoji I've had this
one before
10 out of 10. let's go
oh dude we run almost the same deck
we run almost the exact same deck
wait hold on that's oh wait there was
one more
Cat Skin
let's see you run bomb box niffler book
of monsters
monster book atmospheric charm
yeah that's almost exactly the deck that
I once I hit diamond
I had to uh
I took out the niffler
and I added exposo to try and deal with
all of the
orb of water because there's a lot of
people running the orb
and that'll help get you out of that
and then what else did I take out I took
out atmospheric charm right now because
it's uh
the Norwegian Ridgeback is out of the
game right now
which is mainly why I had it
so yeah that's that's what I ran to
Grand Master right there
how do you send gifts in your personal
space you can set the presence ornament
has some tabs supposedly you can said
good question I have no idea
I have no idea
there's still things about this game
that I'll see in like a menu or
something like wait what
what is that there's so many little
details to this game
Timothy just had an insane thunderstorm
but now you're back
oh wait in real life
oh my goodness yeah we had some crazy
storms a few weeks ago too it's been
kind of a Crazy Summer for storms this
year hope everything's okay dude hope
everything is all right
oh man you guys I think I'm gonna call
it I think I'm gonna end it there
anybody who's wondering if you watch
this video in the replay Squad this was
our deck this was our spell level that
we reached it at
which was I I rarely ever saw anybody
anywhere close to being this low almost
everybody was at least higher than 40
but a lot of them we even saw some
higher than 50. so this these are the
cars that we made it with
I'm gonna be putting out a full video
for you guys explaining how we got here
explaining the last matches we'll
probably do a little breakdown maybe
like the last three matches or so that
we
that we uh
that we had
but man I'm so glad you guys were here
for the ride
so glad you were here for the ride Roger
you just got in at the end
happy Friday Roger
I got the legendary from level eight of
the haunted hollow
level 8 haunted hollow
and honestly like the cards weren't
great
it was these two to start and I'm like
you know that augmenti can be decent
it was my first legendary I was like I
know I probably shouldn't upgrade it
fully but I don't care and I ended up
getting bomb box Pixies and Cassandra
which I use all three of those
so those three definitely definitely
helped out
that came in
came in clutch
so yeah we had a really bad day Tuesday
Migo and stranger I don't know if you
guys heard me say that part or not like
Tuesday was terrible I dropped down
almost
I dropped down
almost back down to 5400 I mean it was
really bad I was just on a huge losing
streak
so then yesterday I said you know what
or Wednesday I guess Wednesday I was
like let's just take this day
and try to trade with people get more
cards to level up do some forests see if
we can't finally get a legendary Echo
and so I upgraded a bunch of cards
because I just kept running to people
that were so much higher than me and I
was like if I'm going to do this as a
free to play player I gotta do it now
because people are only going to get
higher and higher
ranks
as as more people spend money and stuff
so
but yeah so we tanked almost all the way
back down to Rock Bottom
Wednesday was a level up day and then
Thursday we just we just went on a tear
went on a tear today we started the
stream around 7 100 or so somewhere in
there
had a couple of potions to use which are
always good to have we used the big
draft of peace I hit 73.99 I used the
big draft of peace to protect me for the
next three and we won the next three so
we didn't even need it
didn't even need it we just won straight
away
you finally got Bellatrix today trying
to figure out different things I think
you need to swap one card and see what
companions to use yet the companions are
one thing I changed out to I previously
was running Ivy here
but I found the higher levels I've
gotten I feel like not as many people
are using Ron Ron is really strong
but if you know how to deal with him
he's not like he's not too too terrible
but I think so many people were running
Ivy that as we got to higher ranks
people are just like I'm not gonna run
Ron to start things out so you don't see
as much runs once you hit like diamond
at least not for not in the first slot
so I run Cassandra which she is so
strong she has a lot of Health she can
deal with any little any ads like the
small stuff the Monster books the cats
the Pixies
even even the antipody and opoli now the
opolai will stay just outside of her
Circle but that's where something like
expulso comes in you just bounce it
right into her Circle and then she just
zaps it you can also like protect her
with nebulous a little bit I expect
thunderstorm to get banned this week or
next week whatever I'm not sure when
exactly the reset is
I expect thunderstorm and orb of water
to be our next band cards because right
now the the thunderstorm use basically
made nebulous
so so vital to me to get here
so yeah that's kind of why I but you're
that's so funny Migo your deck I've
actually posted a video on it a few days
ago like this deck carried me to Diamond
or something like that
and that's the one that I was breaking
down and talking about but then once I
hit diamond
the orb of water I I knew I had to add a
card
to help me combat orb of water which
still even with esposo it's not a
guarantee you don't hit it every time
also thunderstorms good because if they
throw an orb of water at least you can
fire off a thunderstorm and get some
free damage on them because they they
can't cast nebulous or anything while
they're doing orb
I'm about to hop off uh Jake
or oh no that was Jay-Z dang sorry Jay-Z
guys it's been fun thank you all so much
for being here check out all the other
videos if you're new here make sure you
subscribe to the YouTube channel here we
just crossed 53 000 Subs the other day
thank you guys so much for that big big
big time
we got plenty more magic waking videos
coming we're gonna have a lot to talk
all about this this Grand Master journey
and how we got here
so everybody have a wonderful rest of
your day
as always thank you all so much for
watching
oh I was I thought of a new outro the
other day
this is something I tell my kids every
every night when I pray with my kids we
I pray for these three things for them I
want them to be strong and if that's not
like physically strong
mentally strong emotionally strong be
strong be smart
and to love others man
that's so that I'm gonna I'm gonna try
to add that to my outro every I'm gonna
be like guys be strong be smart show
love to others
as always thank you all so much for
watching
I'll talk to you again soon
later guys thank you for being here glad
you were here for this journey
it was awesome